not um tested any of the hey what's up
man I do say GIF do you not say GIF it's
GIF I've heard of JF
e but that's what the
J isn't
it Oh wait we're already yelling we're
already
yelling do
they okay it's word of God
I mean you're you're right and when
you're right you're right but that's a
GE you
know it's I know it's true it's true but
you know sometimes I say things wrong
just because I like being wrong or
something I don't know but anyway all
right
so nobody can hear y'all just yet hold
up guys hold
up
oh yeah oh yeah
absolutely so
like so I'm gonna I'm gonna I'm going to
take a second guys nobody can hear y'all
just yet which is weird because I can
hear you hey my fellow streamers what's
going on here man it's going it's going
to my uh to my headphones but it's not
like actually coming
through
oh
yeah oh I need to disable streamer mode
hold
up oh never mind no that didn't work
y'all y'all just say
something oh yeah they heard they heard
me debating you you know the the debate
before the debate yeah all right well
we're cutting into time so let me figure
this out real quick guys so sorry give
me a
second okay okay
gotcha so that would be what just an
audio input
[Music]
or oh I got you I got you I got you well
well let us see this real
quick okay
so that's not
work
and I went to a game stop because I had
to pick up Tick seven and then I saw uh
Duo there and I'm like is it working now
it is I believe it
is cool I can hear
you
cool whatever I saw the daroo statue
there I'm like man it's this that's
that's way too damn big like
that Dar is a big boy okay so let me go
ahead and they're hearing you twice
they're hearing you twice though you're
hear me twice yeah so you might have to
mute yourself on OBS I think yeah and or
just go mono settings instead of stereo
yeah because if you mute yourself here
then we won't hear you we won't hear you
so I think you have to M yourself
through so I I
muted in
OBS so how are we now
guys it's better now I don't hear any
Echo okay but y'all can still hear me I
people are saying there we go finally it
worked all right
yeah okay and apparently you're quiet so
raise see if you can raise your volume
on I can raise mine I can raise mine so
I should be this should be a bit my
microphone closer I guess yeah technical
difficulties well this is probably why
people do that little thing called you
know a sound test an audio test before
you know but it's what's that bit who
does who does that right all right yeah
Bandit don't do that you know if we're
if we're
fine then I'm just going to go for it
all right you guys go ahead and
introduce yourselves we're about 5
minutes into our yes we can hear you hi
we're about 5 minutes into our uh time
slot so y'all go ahead and introduce
yourselves from the top right we've got
HMK what do you do sir what's up ladies
and gentlemen it is your boy HMK once
again I do a lot of content over on
YouTube twitch Twitter Instagram Tik Tok
now the whole shebang I focus mainly on
the Legend of Zelda Kingdom Hearts all
things Nintendo square and of course
Super Smash Brothers and we're here to
talk about the debate of Tears of the
kingdom and got a lot to say about it
because I love this game
so yeah that's all I'm going to say for
now fantastic fantastic and Mr
Commonwealth
realm yes I'm also on YouTube primarily
doing a little bit on exclusive stuff on
patreon these days as well uh Twitter as
well uh not so much on Twitch uh it's
it's not my thing unfortunately uh
things got in the way in 2023 but yeah
I'm currently working on a bunch of
Zelda stuff uh including the first Zelda
theory of 2024 so that's nice uh switch
2 uh since it's probably a new system
year and uh who knows maybe we could get
uh tears of the Kingdom Deluxe 4K there
that would be
awesome we've already got a super chat
in here but let's go through the
introduction still we have uh Mr GIF
Zelda how do I what is your actual
name GI world the gift Zelda man the
gift Zelda man that's
new what go ahead so most people just
call most people just call me GIF but
really whatever but um I'm a little
concerned were we supposed to play Tears
of the Kingdom before
this you
know it no of course yes I beat that a
month in so hello everyone Zelda
gifworld here uh mostly on Twitter doing
lots of Zelda gifs Zelda Ms if you've
ever seen a post a Zelda post and rolled
your eyes it was probably mine on there
uh just broke into
streaming about six or seven months ago
on twitch under Zelda GIF world and have
been having a blast doing that kind of
getting out there and guess what this is
my first like show ever right now yeah
guys didn't know that but yes this is my
first one so hyped so excited to do it
with with all of you you're sorry yeah
no I'm sorry because you know like this
is your first one and the host can't get
it together man what the hell but anyway
I'm so excited for each and every one of
youall to be on and yes I am I I'm
reading chat I know that I'm still too
quiet I'm going to get right to that but
we're doing introductions um Miss
nimbley we we have not uh talked before
this really but I met you a few days ago
how are you you and what are you up to
hi um it's nice to meet you I don't know
I should look if I should look at I'm
looking at everyone's cameras but uh
yeah I'm Nimble uh I primarily create on
Twitch but I've been tiptoeing my way to
YouTube I mostly focus on lore I think
most of us here are lore enjoyers um and
I like high and Dark Fantasy games uh I
love Zelda I love Dark Souls and I'm
happy to chat with everyone thanks for
having
me nice awesome well love having you on
uh so we're gonna go ahead and get
things started here um oh we lost HMK
there he goes just as as soon as it
started there he goes do I have to be
the Hy person now I'm I'm still you guys
can't hear me we can hear you okay no
it's it's the the video my camera's
resetting give it a second all
right well anyway so what we're going to
do while he's while he is with us in
spirit and not um physically we're going
to go ahead and I'm just going to I have
a few questions for you guys if that's
okay and there he goes and here he is I
have a few questions for you guys there
and uh it's it's kind of what's going to
get us kicked off we also had a super
chat right off the bat so we're going to
get to that as well um but as far as my
discussion questions are concerned and
the way that we're going to kind of
answer these is I'm just going to go in
the same uh uh order
as what we just did for the
introductions this is very topical to
you in your opinion what makes a Zelda
game a Zelda game as opposed to any
ordinary action adventure game out there
and I and this this isn't necessarily
like oh okay what made Zelda games Zelda
games back in the day in the 80s when
nothing else was on the market I'm
talking about like today what is the
Zelda game Mr HK oh I'm starting let's
go all right wait wait Can Am I Frozen
still no no you're good no you're good
right I'm because I have both screens on
okay so what makes a Zelda game a Zelda
game and this is I feel is applied yes
sir re Bob to both breath of the wild
and tears of the Kingdom Zelda games
first and foremost have to have the
right balance of the three Virtues Of A
Zelda game gameplay wise before I get
into like aesthetic or anything like
that all right and the three virtues
that must be in balance is
exploration combat and puzzles whether
if the game is open world or not whether
the game is linear or not whether the
game is structured in a certain way or
the uh what you call uh the endgame must
be presented in a certain way because
for the longest when it came to 2D and
3D zillas they always you know
structured under what is known as the
Zelda formula but that formula has been
thrown out the window in my opinion for
for the better in order to help lull
along the evolution of this franchise
while still incorporating those three
virtues now of course beyond the aspect
of gameplay The Legend of Zelda for the
most part and up until now of course you
know breal was like sneaking in some you
know magic technology but we've seen
that with previous you know Zelda games
to varying degrees in which the legend Z
must be within that of high fantasy in
terms of presentation you know a
Fantastical land where magic and
possibly Magi technology is abound in in
varing levels of degree where it's like
oh this magic ever oh Magic is dying in
this specific land or in this specific
world of hyru or lebrina Hollow drum the
great sea the Twilight real any of that
it must retain that aspect of high
fantasy while also incorporating the
gameplay virtues of puzzles exploration
and combat and even if people were to
say things like oh Skyward Sword it was
lenar so how can you say exploration
like it's still incorporate exploration
because I mean like it that game
although it being the most linear of
any's of the game you still have to look
around for stuff you like it doesn't
like oh push you in One Direction it's
like hey as as long as you go down this
hallway Temple of Time in Twilight
Princess then you get to the end
regardless no you still have to look
around and incorporate the puzzles in
order to move forward despite it being
the most linear so without going off to
off going to off the rails that is what
a Zelda game is to me I I like that oh I
can hear myself
now whoops I tried to okay can you guys
hear me twice or once in the Discord
chat once once cool yeah how about you
guys you know watch
it can you hear my voice
yet anyway we're just going to go with
it because I'm trying to fix things
behind the scenes while you guys are
talking but Mr Commonwealth realm what
makes a Zelda game a Zelda game I would
say it's mostly a structured and
balanced experience uh apart from the
things that HMK uh talked about but it's
also the fact that Zelda was the Dungeon
Crawler until the age of breath the Wild
and tears of the Kingdom uh this
franchise stood way above uh in terms of
its structure in terms of its level
design and themes uh themes very very
deep and Zelda wasn't shy of going the
religious route sometimes we saw that
with the controversies in Notre enough
time we saw that in Skyward Sword with
the Buddhist and hinduist uh
Inspirations in the ancient system and I
think that is kind of where the Zelda
franchise stands it's a franchise that
takes a lot of inspiration from our own
world uh but at the same times adds that
high fantasy to it uh and creativity
that only does Zelda team in kyota is
able to provide I think that is the best
way of defining it and when it comes to
tears of the Kingdom we'll get to it but
I feel like there's still steps to be
made to bring it back to the peak
dungeon Zelda that we have been used to
since the very first one in
1986 Fair very fair all right give
man all right so I know one of the first
things you said is don't go back to the
beginning so I'm immediately going to go
back to the
beginning there and just just from the
first game it just such a sense of
wonder for that and from that game you
established so many enemies So Many
Music so much sound and every single
game without exception has built on that
where the games are different but they
always feel so familiar and a lot of
that is is the music is the enemies even
though they look a little different
they're all the same even the sound
effects they just draw you back into the
Zelda World in a way that just other
games and other series don't do that in
my opinion it it makes you want to
explore it makes you want to kind of
look in every nook in the game and
that's what has always drawn me to that
is that I know I'm going into a game
that is going to be familiar to me I
know I'm going back into a world even if
it's a different story like from
Twilight Princess the Skyward Sword even
if they're completely different stories
Wind Waker heck toun link
but they're so similar too that you
just it's just it's yeah there's a form
essentially yes there's there are
similarities from game to game I I
actually agree pretty much with
everything you just said there um but
I'm gonna I'm gonna let you uh go ahead
and finish what you were saying
there yeah um yeah just the familiarity
how everything Builds on it you get the
different versions of the same music but
they kick it up a notch and it just you
know you can just kind of feel the way
you felt like if you hear a song in
breath of the wild that you've heard
versions of in Skyward
or yeah when Waker or Twilight it kind
of brings you back to the feelings and
emotions through all of those games and
it kind of just catches up on you at
once and I really just don't feel any
other series does that it's really
special it's you know I I think it's
great whenever you hear like you just
said especially with music just like a
theme that you remember from 20 years
ago that pops back up I mean at Kera
right everybody freaks out over K's them
because it's like Wind Waker was a thing
that happened and this is also a Zelda
game oh my God but anyway uh Nimble I
there's a K in your name I'm so sorry I
know I'm going to say Kimble but
Nimble it's okay the K is silent Like a
Knife um Like a Knife God like L um I
think for me um if I could just give a
brief backstory I came to Zelda games
pretty late in life um I started with
like Shooters and then my way to the
from software series and then to Zelda
so I feel like one thing that I know is
distinct about Zelda versus other high
and Dark Fantasy games are that sense
of I I don't want to say Nostalgia
because that's not exactly the word but
it's almost like what uh uh GIF was
saying you have those connections
through through music and that sense of
exploration throughout the series and
even though sometimes there will be
Whispers of previous games in whatever
New Generation there is and it's not
really expanded upon I think the fact
that Zelda is able to maintain its
Essence through its musicality its
environmental storytelling and even
references to characters is what makes
it so unique and for me I started I hope
no one will be upset with me about this
but I started with breath of the wild
and then I went to acarina and I think
that when I first was playing through
all the Zelda games I felt like oh
birath of the wild I still feel like is
my favorite but I still keep going back
to how I felt playing through Ocarina
for the first time because I felt like I
went through Link's journey through
childhood and adulthood with him even
though I am in my 30s playing it for the
first time and I have played pretty much
every from software like Fantasy game
those games are very scary and they have
that same essence of Zelda with the
swords and you know a sense of grief and
loss but I feel like what felt so
special to me about Zelda is that it
takes the struggles that both fictional
and real life people deal with with it's
like a sense of doubt about your ability
but still having to take on life's
challenges but you are able to achieve
those things through perseverance
through your community like through your
companions and just like that inner
sense of knowing that you're doing
what's right and you're going to do it
regardless of how difficult it is like I
think that that for me is what stands
out about Zelda even in dependent of
like the gameplay mechanics it's just
that sense of like that Nintendo magic
of we should keep that child sense of
wonder and courage throughout our life
anyway that was a long answer but no no
no clearly it was the best one because
you mentioned AAR of time off the bat so
you know I'm I'm I'm leaning towards
that one I'm just kidding uh but no
seriously that it was I
think from your
answers it kind of proves the entire
notion that I had about uh the way that
people relate to these amazing games uh
which is why I I set this up anyway
we've got more open-ended uh you know
kind of like so long as it's an
adventure game and and if if I'm
misinterpreting any of y'all's answers
please correct me um but we've got more
open-ended uh stances like you know it's
it's about the adventure and the puzzles
then we've got a bit more specific we've
got you know it's about the Zelda
formula and like the repeating elements
that come back you know um the sense of
childlike wonder you know and I think I
think that that
is I I don't know I think that that
right there is kind of a testament to a
great series which we can all agree on
right something that appeals to
everybody for different reasons um but
that leads me directly into my next
question uh so are the era of the Wild
Games Zelda games why or why not and
what we're going to do here he took his
glasses off I'm scared what we're going
to do here is we're going to go in the
inverse order if that uh is okay so
Nimble if you don't mind um put in
I'm putting I'm putting him at the end
so that you know so that he puts his
glasses back up no I'm just kidding
could you repeat the question what are
are the era of the Wild
Games Zelda games based
on basically based on your own uh
criteria
H I think in their
Essence yes because for me
it h
I haven't played through Zelda 1 and two
yet but my understanding is that the era
of the Wild Games was meant to return to
that um sense of open
exploration and more of the story being
the individual players experience and
not necessarily the literal story that's
being told and in that sense I would say
yes but even to my own personal answer I
feel like it's uh maybe because for me
what feels like the most Zelda game sa
for Ocarina is Twilight Princess I know
that not everyone enjoys Twilight
Princess but that's my personal favorite
I love Twilight um I think that for me
what I
enjoy about the Zelda series is almost
that linearity in Exploration and
storytelling I enjoy that I can explore
um infinitely in the wild era but having
started with that and gone through and I
actually finished Twilight Princess
right before tears came out it was
incredibly jarring to go from that
playthrough experience the tears even
though I enjoyed it and I felt almost
disconnected from what I
had
felt playing as Link in Twilight
Princess versus tears and I don't want
to take up too much time talking about
why that I felt that way but it's a
maybe I think I would I would like to
see them dial it back a little bit and
it'll feel more like Zelda so I I let me
be a bit more um that was a fantastic
answer but I just just in case anybody's
confused about that question let me
specify it just a little bit more before
we go on I heard or I saw a comment the
other day that was very um introspective
I
think and the way that they put it was
if you were to describe to someone that
a new indie game had come come out that
was really cool and you were like it's a
Zelda type like it's a it's a Zelda
likee game um there are already off the
bat these images that come into your
mind right about dungeon crawling about
getting loot you know stuff like that
like that is how you that is how you
describe like that is a Zelda likee um
indie game like I I have something like
I have something to say about that okay
okay and by the way we don't have to
just go in order if people have stuff to
say just just just come out at me you
know what I mean but the reason why I
set that up is because
um nobody like if you were to strip
everything away from the air of the Wild
games right as far as uh naming is
concerned take the Legend of Zelda out
of the name right I know this that's
that's that's the question right take
Link the name link out take the name
zeld out the name Goron the name read
whatever take all of the naming
out and what are you left with would you
describe that as a Zelda type basically
that that is what the question is so uh
I I just want to interject that point
when you're like zelot types and stuff
like that whenever I see an whenever I
see someone say that I feel that's
hyperfocusing on one aspect of Zelda or
even one specific genre that Zelda has
explored throughout its entire like
franchise because zulla has been
constantly evolving and that's like
something that the zulla team has always
say that is not a secret right so when
people bring up like oh this IND Z like
I'm like uh no like Zelda inspired sure
but Zelda like Zelda the Legge of Zelda
is as a franchise is way too erratic
when it comes to its specific injuries
to have an established Zelda like unlike
that of so like soulsborne you know like
oh Souls like or you know anything like
that because you bring up tunic it's
like okay that's 2D Zelda like you know
oh the action adventure game in a 3D
space Oh people can say that's a Souls
like depending on its difficulty because
that's like the one thing they
hyperfocus on when it comes to that
style of game even though it functions
for the most part like a 3D Zelda and
then when you say something like oh
let's strip this down without link
without this what do you get is it still
a Zelda like the funniest thing that you
brought up about when when you bring
that up is that oh if you were to do
that to a link to the past you know like
people say oh one of the best Zelda
games ever on the super NS if you were
to strip that out and hyperfocus on that
aspect of is z like you get uh Goof
Troop the
game you you literally literally get
Goof Troop the
game hey a like right oh play it play
It's A Link to the Past It's A Link to
the Past hey hey you know if it has you
know linear progression gear that
unlocks different parts of the m and you
know other stuff yeah you're you're
right it probably is a Zelda type um and
also like I made a mistake guys I put
these groups at 30 minutes apart holy
cow I am already saying I mean we had a
lot of time a lot you had a lot of time
to set up so I mean right I mean it's
true it's true but anyway um so U you
know what one all to go ahead and and
pop in we're not doing orders
anymore I guess I'll I guess I'll pop in
and and starting this I I kind of fig
I'm like we're going to be talking about
Goof Troop today aren't we I I just had
a feeling just had a feeling in the back
of my head apparently I missed the
memo this is a good game go play it like
super good game sounds great actually I
actually heard it's really good is it
the person who did Resident Evil 4 do
that game if I remember correctly it was
developed by ccom if I'm sure which I
mean could probably be the reason why n
tell is like hey remember Goof Troop
let's get those guys on Oracle like
yeah go troop like is
go is it Disney yes
it's goof okay goof tro sorry you play
as goofy and Max in the game mhm I
finally understand I'm a cool kid
go but uh one thing uh I thought was
interesting as when nimely was talking
earlier was when she said that she
started with breath of the wild in
Ocarina of Time and I absolutely love
how people can come into this series in
different ways it's just amazing some
people start with the OG some people
start with tears of the Kingdom
Go in different orders and it just I
think it could just bring us all
different experiences together loving
the same series and franchise and that
was just kind of cool to hear about that
but uh on topic with your question is
tears and breath of the wild Zelda games
I absolutely think they are I I really
do I by the way for the record sorry
go so the reason I think that is these
new games I feel have are just like the
other ones they just give you options
that's all now with like tiers you could
go to any of the four places that you
wanted to go once you hit hyru there you
could go to uh R the bird people you
could go to gudo so it wasn't linear
where you had to go to one to one to one
because you needed an item but
nevertheless you still had to pick one
of them and it just gave you some
options you still have to do them all
it's not like you can just really not uh
do any of them and then once you get to
them maybe it's not a traditional
dungeon but still it's dungeon-like it's
still kind of the same formula you have
to go through it you have to find Keys
you have to find items you have to get
through it um it just feels like they
took the like Twilight princesses the
wind wakers and just added some more
modern features on them there for you to
say put a waypoint on your map when
you're trying to go somewhere or they
put it on there for you and then when
you're getting there there's so many
things in between that you can do it's
the option you can go right to your
destination or you can do the five
million things in between it's just
getting options it's the spirit of it
and I very much think both of them are
very much Zelda
games yeah very good very good and
Conrad
yeah I would turn the question a little
bit around because yes they are Zelda
games but are they the two best Zelda
games that's my uh more approach because
these games feel less Zelda than some
prior Zelda titles that's the best way
of defining I think breath the Wild and
tears of the Kingdom because they went
more away from what is safe Zelda and
went into more of what can I say
experimental yeah experimental that
that's the that's the word I'm
definitely looking at uh and some of the
it's it's very much a hit and miss uh in
many regards some of the things are just
miles better than what we used to have
While others just feel like yeah maybe
you should have gone with this instead
from uh the 3D past and I think we are
in that stage where we're TR still
trying to figure out that perfect Zelda
formula for this open air genre I think
we still haven't gotten there but we're
making small steps towards it I think
tears of the Kingdom
has step in the right direction after
let's
say bre pulled down the old Zelda house
and tried to use the framework that that
is Zelda and try to fill it out with a
little bit different uh aspects and
mechanics uh but tears of the Kingdom in
with tears of the Kingdom Zelda team
realized yes we need to yes we're going
to keep this because it's very popular
and people Vibe with it but at the same
time we have to look at what work from
the serious past and dungeons was
definitely the one thing that they took
to heart that needed to come back in its
more traditional form but I feel like it
ended pretty much there as well it
didn't go much further than that when it
came to a little bit boss variety so
things that were related to dungeons
that that's where I would say uh they
brought it back to what defines Zelda
but there's still aspects that could
definitely be worked on uh story and the
way you do storytelling is definitely
one of them I also want to add to what
Conrad was saying is that um it felt
almost as though they were going in the
direction of like an Eco or Shadow of
the Colossus with the wild era which is
another one of the series that I played
before ever playing Zelda where you have
this
like grandiose world that you're a part
of but you're this little guy and you're
not totally sure of the direction that
you're supposed to go but you know that
you're supposed to save this person or
save or prevent this great evil from
befalling Hyrule and I hope that they
lean a little bit more into that like I
I remember when I first played birth of
the wild I didn't go towards King Rome I
dropped down to where the first stone
Talis is and I just had a twig and I was
like oh my God it's like Shadow of the
Colossus and I part of me almost hopes
that we have like that dungeon style
boss but in the Overworld
that I I feel like that'll make the open
exploration a little bit more fun at
least for me anyway sorry to interrupt
it came through my
mind one thing that I that I really
liked from uh breath of the wild to
tears is I was not a huge fan of the
Divine beast but mostly because they all
look the same if I sent you a picture
from one of them and said hey which
Divine Beast is that you probably won't
be able to tell me that I'm just kidding
though I I get what you're
saying okay most people wouldn't be able
to say which one it is and with the
temple CEST Dungeons and tear they got
them a lot more on theme they were a lot
different and I and I enjoyed that a lot
more yeah absolutely so okay guys um
like I said I'm big dumb and I only gave
us 30 minutes per group so to be
respectful of the next group that's
going to come in here um I'm going to
just ask yall the wrap-up question
question um and we're just going to go
through it very briefly okay all right
what's up man I didn't get to give my
answer if if T the kingom breath of w no
I didn't I just interjected earlier but
I didn't give mine I was biting my time
I haven't taken on my glasses off my bad
man my bad so I get I get no no no no
you can you can give that answer uh
y'all go ahead and stew over the
question what if you could craft your
perfect ideal Zelda game in the future
what would that look like like so y'all
St over that Mr HMK take it
away now I'm going to say a lot of
things that a lot of people aren't going
to like right and I've seen I've been
I've been reading like chat especially
in the beginning before this uh I want
to bring that up where someone's like oh
HMK is one of those guys that like hey
uh don't question just consume just
consume Pro I've never seen him dislike
a game or anything like that because
it's it's become no secret that tears of
the Kingdom I adore tears of the Kingdom
and yes tears of the kingdom and breath
of the wild are indeed Zelda games
they're just the next Evolution that
people aren walking with at the moment
same way is if you guys weren't there
when aaran time came onto the picture
everyone says aaran time was like the 10
out of 10 and I believe so as as it was
but when that game first came
out y'all y'all ain't ready for that
conversation but to go on to the point
when people like oh I think every game
is good I have n Negative Man and I'm
telling y'all y'all do not want me to
talk about Link's Awakening or Twilight
Princess right because just to give you
guys a little taste to that everyone's
like in this day and age when it comes
to breath of the wild and tears of the
Kingdom how people are saying like if
it's a Zelda game or not it's not a
Zelda game it's week here it's week here
a week there they're hyperfocusing and
I'm using that word a lot because that's
what I see a lot when it comes to the
open air approach and refusing to
acknowledge that Dungeons and like I've
seen people talk about the dungeons so
much about tears of the kingdom and the
Divine Beast about bre OFW they hardly
ever talk about you know the 120 and the
150 shrines in each game which is
something I felt was such a magical
experience in terms of finding these
shrines and when these shrines are
shrines where they have their own mini
structured dungeons or puzzles that is
something that I feel is literally
dungeons of your just broken up into
spots that are sprinkled around the the
vast world and the vaster world from
breath of wild two tiar of the Kingdom
but when Twilight Princess came out
ladies and gentlemen everyone's saying
that like hey why can't breath of wild
tear is going be more like Twilight
Princess in terms of dungeon in terms of
structure of the game when Twilight
Princess came out sure got really good
reviews in the most part in terms of the
hardcore uh video game Outlet you know
or in some aspects of the Zelda fan base
but man oh man if you want me to pull up
the reseats the
people hated Twilight Princess when it
first came out they said the game was
incredibly derivative of Aur time Wind
Waker not so much major mask because
major mask like it was a really big
shape of when compared to that of a time
but they hated Twilight appr Princess
the the the dungeons derivative the
dungeon items yo let's let's have a use
for this item and only have the use to
open up the next dungeon without having
any type of substantial use in the
Overworld the spinner hello you want to
go out and go find one or two heart
heart pieces in the overw world be my
guest Twilight princess's linearity in
terms of specific dungeons was
incredibly frowned upon literally I
brought up earlier in this point
Twilight Princess not Twilight Princess
uh Temple of Time was a hallway go back
and play it it was a hallway you go to
the front you go to the back that that
that's it so when it came to like the
whole argument that I'm seeing now it's
just so funny to me that
tears of the kingdom is going through
right now the almost exact same
situation Tyler princess did when it
first came out and give it 5 10 you know
yeah 5 10 years people are going to look
back and like tears of the Kingdom best
of the game no no no no no no no no
sorry H I have to interrupt there
because tears of the Kingdom has a
number of structural issues uh it is
very unbalanced compared to previous
Zelda games okay uh it feels
disconnected compared to P elegans which
had far more structure but I'm I'm going
answer that with some because Twi
princess although it having structure
also worked against it that's what I'm
saying tears of the kingdom and breath
of the wild a lot of people refuse to
acknowledge the fact that Dungeons and
the world itself and even the story had
to be adapted in order to accommodate
the Open Air Adventure a lot of people
don't like that and that's fine what I'm
saying is that you can't say something
like this what I'm saying is that you
can't say something like this tears of
the kingdom and Bre theal have bad
stories that's not true if I were to
structure the story in storytelling bad
story story bad bad presentation that's
what I'm saying yeah agree if I were to
structure that's a it is a flaw but the
story itself a lot of people hyper focus
on the on the idea or the fact the story
the story was weak the story was not
weak the way it was presented is week
and that also is something up for debate
if I were to structure tears of the
kingd or breath of the Wild story in a
sense that it would be more linear or
more structured like Twilight Princess
wind all that stuff people were like oh
my dear Zelda how could she go through
all that I mean if you guys beat tears
of the Kingdom spoilers I'm not gonna
say spoiler but I'm like feel sad that's
the point what I'm saying is that tears
of the kingdom is facing the same type
of ridicule Twilight Princess did when
it first came out but now we're in the
day and age where everyone is saying not
everyone but I mean a lot of saying but
HK I have to say one thing here and that
is that the Zelda team tried to just do
too much with tears of the Kingdom they
tried to and the problem is they didn't
manage to balance all the three layers
together uh and focused way too much on
the surface Again The Depths feel like
an almost completely optional area which
is very bloated and tedious and the sky
islands are underdeveloped that is my
main issue with this game okay but I
could also say that's what I'm saying
like when when you say oh it's not the
same it's it's it is it is very similar
I won't say it's the same because I mean
nothing exactly is the same these are
more structural issues yeah but then you
can also I I like when it comes to
design issues you're going to tell me
that the Overworld for Twilight Princess
was developed you're going to tell me
that the hidden village was developed
when you go there twice even though it's
like it's a town area yeah but that was
an era of system limitations we are no
longer there HMK that's the difference
exactly and that's why the limitations
are broken in the sense for tears of the
kingdom and Bre the wild to explore all
of this and explore a grander open but
tear of the Kingdom I'm literally rring
the same territory I did for the last
six years right it is a good reason why
a lot of people have fallen off and
that's not seeing them appeal and to
even beat the king that's that's the
whole idea of a sequel we've Liv we're
living in the day and age where people
are like literally taking a detriment
that I feel doesn't exist like back in
the day if people were to play Jack 2 to
Jack 3 people have the same complaints
yes z z is an action
RPG by definition an RPG needs to have
roles Zelda is not really an action RPG
it's more of an action adventure
semantics but I will say if it's a
sequel we already have a foundation that
we're starting with if you continue a
story with a poorly executed Story by
definition I think that is bad yeah but
then
we're not limited by Hardware when we're
writing a story so I like that's but
then why are you hyp focusing the story
when I'm story when I'm playing a game
as a I understand that you care about a
story when playing a game but I care
about the gameplay when playing a
game so much when it comes to compared
that breath of the wild and I and I love
that I haven't talked about the story
like at all I'm talking about the more
game design issues that this game has
the lack of Focus the lack of uh balance
between the layers like I feel like I'm
spending 70 to% down on the surface when
it was clear that the marketing was
promising more of a sky adventure and
what is in the sky almost it's so uh
deprived of life that's the main issue I
have with this game like this could have
been easily solved if you had a
civilization in the sky and the depths
then suddenly it would be far more uh
enticing to explore these territories
instead of just going to the same type
of Sky Island which has been in many
cases just replicated across this map
like when you look at the uh you can
take the maps of the sky the surface and
the depths and you will see how empty
the top layer is compared to those other
two and in my opinion The Depths were
way overblown they didn't need to be
that big especially when you have the
same kind of
grayness uh across across the board it
is very bloated and very repetitive and
that is not a subjective matter that is
objective because when you have so many
hours you can't say that no you can't
because I can say something like oh the
sky I was never promised life in the sky
I was promised being able to explore
that with different types of zonai type
of Creations that I'm able to create in
this game unlike that of breath of the
wal that give me an extra layer of
exploration I don't need any type of
life in that sense of exploration as
long long as there's things to explore
and to find that can only be found up
there which is true it's so repetitive
it's so repetitive it's either referee
for a second um just just you know to
keep things a bit more structured um we
I think that at this point we we do have
a good idea of where you guys are coming
from however I would like to funnel a
bit by the way I moved the next group to
um the next hour so we have at least 15
minut O N I feel bad about that no no no
no it's okay it's okay like I honestly I
should have done that anyway uh but we
have a super chat question that didn't
pop up on the screen but whatever
um they they they're not sure how there
it is I I wi it into existence but
anyway they're not sure how to say it
but uh let us talk about the continuity
between breath of the wild and tears of
the Kingdom uh so do we feel that tears
of the Kingdom felt like and I'm not
even talking about the rest of the
friend
at this point we simply talking about
between breath of the wild and tears of
the Kingdom did it feel like a sequel
lorewise
storywise not gameplay necessarily I
would say yes um and just to use an but
it's it's done in a subtle way so for
example the dueling Peaks um we get drip
for that in breath of the wild if you go
to the faen stable there's an inpc that
tells you about the origin of how them
dueling Peaks split in half and if you
go to the depths in tears of the Kingdom
directly underneath the dueling Peaks
there is a giant dragon skeleton um so
there's there's a little bit of that and
if you go to different areas that seemed
kind of barren that have uh like trees
that are white bark with orange leaves
if you go to those areas in tears of the
Kingdom there's something cool there so
and if you're exploring you'll find a
lot of continuity but as for the
overarching story I'll defer to you all
I I would also like to place within the
lens of this question um you know people
not remembering link things like that
that's what I was about to
say freaking
classroom a whole classroom of people
who forgot link I have an interesting
thought about why that could be a thing
but I'm going let her speak
first so do how did it feel that was my
exact thing it's like I I I link just
saved the entire world in this huge
gigantic battle there's newspapers Lucky
Clover Gazette they got pen there
writing stories and everything how does
nobody know who I am I'm going places
people like you know I just remember
that classroom in uh hatano Village
there where you go in and there like oh
some legendary hero save the day and I'm
like and I feel like that Meme where I'm
like when you're in the corner it's like
nobody knows I'm the legendary
hero there and it
just like I like the things like uh
nimely was saying about you kind of like
the small homages to the other game and
things that could kind of carry over but
with just like recognizing link it just
seemed weird to me that no one just
seemed to know him or events from the
last game and also where the heck are
all the guardian you know Guardian in
trash where where where did that go they
just throw it down to the depths because
I didn't see it I felt that Guardian
stuff was like repurposed just like they
final all and then that's what helped
build the towers as you can see like the
recycling's good recycling great but
that that's another one of those um big
blatant things about choose the kingdom
that we do just have to come up with a
bunch of you know uh head Cannon to
explain um and there was plenty of that
in breath of the wild too I'm not
specifying that for only tears of the
kingdom but tears of the kingdom does
have it kind of as a double whammy
because it's breath of the wild wasn't a
direct sequel right breath of the wild
was and in the future dot dot dot in the
franchise eventually breath of the wild
happened uh CH of the kingdom is
legitimately like no like three years
ago whatever that's debated is when
breath of the wild happened now tears of
the kingdom is happening and three or
four years ago there were all these
other shika Towers all these other shika
shrines all the you know all the
remnants of Guardians around the place
like you're saying the Divine beasts
whatever um and it's just gone in tears
of the Kingdom but in a recent interview
they literally said that it just kind of
disappeared Into Thin Air just you know
because it's its purpose was done
which so I think one of the key um
Concepts here is that you you can
answer you know you can answer for the
discrepancies but what happens when it's
not a very good answer I think that's I
think that's what bothers a lot of
people because when when you just kind
of Slam people with the whole like it
disappeared you know it's like well that
that kind of that kind of sucks you know
I'm um I'm going to say one thing here
Bandit and that is the fact that when
people don't care about the lore and
story which we have seen a lot with
tears of the Kingdom they finished the
game and pretty much moved on to the
next thing that kill kills the community
uh and that's kind of what we have seen
in the last span of 8 seven months I
would say since the launch of the game
it was people were oh in the moon the
the views were amazing uh for say up to
August and then interest just collapsed
which was not the case with breath of
the wild in the slightest and which is
not really the case with other Zelda
games that comes out because there's so
much to theorize about there's so much
to talk about well in this game it feels
like just those other games where you
just finish them and move on to the next
one with Zelda usually you stay there
with it and I feel like the fallof rate
with this game has been much higher than
we saw with breath the Wild and other P
Zelda games especially breath the wild
which we want to compare it because the
open air genre is pretty fresh for Zelda
and in this case it is clear that people
have less interest in Zelda uh at the
end of uh TI of the kingdom and how do
we know this we see that there hasn't
been a bump uh a boost in views uh
compared to before the game's launch uh
which it would have had if it came with
a lot of answers with a lot of uh
exciting new lore that doesn't
just doesn't have the same punch as we
are used to in The Legend of Zelda's
post so we as the creators Behind The
Legend of Zelda right we and we did have
another Super Chat but it didn't look
like it was a question I think it was
more of a comment um but anyway uh we we
as the creators get to kind of feel the
pulse of the community
numerically not everybody gets to feel
that like we have like we have
legitimate analytics behind our videos
right and like if we see of you spike
for Zelda as a topic we're the ones who
are going to legitimately feel that
right so with that Advantage though I
think that um a lot of us have been
feeling a bit of the
disinterest that's been but here's the
other thing right I wasn't on the I
wasn't on the ground as a Creator uh
when breath of the wild came out I mean
I was but like I was the channel was
nothing um I I think I kind of popped up
around uh the time that the breath of
the wild sequel uh trailers started
coming into existence or into fruition
uh but when breath of the wild uh came
out I don't know what it felt like
everybody who was around at that point
so I think um of this group excuse me
correct me if I'm wrong but that should
be uh Commonwealth realm in HMK you guys
were around on the scene when breath of
the wild came out and I'm not sure about
the other two but uh I've heard that
there was and I'm sorry I hit my mic
there I've heard that there was like a
drop right in in interest uh right after
the game came out but here we are it's
about to be a year that tears of the
Kingdom has been out which is crazy uh
but yeah it's about to be a year um and
we're we're still as far as I can tell
we're only
seeing a continual
decline in in the interest uh not just
about tears of the Kingdom about the
universe of the Legend of
Zelda why is that I can give a very
specific answer to that and that is that
it's it's a general impression I have
because we are talking about people that
are very much in the Zelda fan base I'm
I like to talk with people that are more
casual
uh with the that enjoy the zeld deore
but are not as fanatical as as we are
sure uh and many of those people that
I've talked to both in my home country
in the US and other places they played
tears of the Kingdom but they haven't
beaten the game and you know why because
they just get to a point and they say
this is just too much uh I feel like
this is just taking way too much of of
my time without getting the payoff I
feel like I'm just rereading the same
path as I did in breath of the Wild and
it just doesn't motivates me that the
whole feeling of Discovery when they
have to put discovery on the screen for
me to just as a breath of the Wild
player to know that oh this is something
new that wasn't in breath of the wild
that's when you know that you have made
a wrong step and I think a lot of people
have the same experience and feeling
from uh this game that it feels like a
1.5 more than a two when it comes to
breath the wild I understand that by the
way um so we did extend the time a
little bit but I'm not going to do it
again just out of respect for the other
people so we're going to get we got five
minutes left um let's go ahead and just
have closing thoughts in general from
each of you um y'all can just go in
whatever
order not everybody all at once all
right Mr I enjoyed oh sorry um I enjoyed
tears of the Kingdom for what it was I
do do hope that and I don't know how
this would happen but being someone that
enjoys both gameplay and story I want to
see like a marriage of the two in
whatever the next Zelda is going to be
because coming from the fromsoft
community I know that story is what
keeps a community alive like it's a
reason why people are still talking
about stuff that happen in Dark Souls
which came out well almost a decade ago
because the story is is there it's just
it's cryp and I feel like
Zelda I know people have different
opinions about what's important in the
game but for me I love that sense of
adventure and that sense
of uh like responsibility I have because
I'm invested in the the story I didn't
feel as invested in the characters and
tears of the Kingdom because it just
felt like they were going in too many
different directions and key characters
got like barely any development in my
opinion and when things happen to them I
it was sad but only because I knew it
was supposed to be sad not because I
felt a sense
of grief for them so I hope that they
even if it's just like a few a little
bit more fleshed out I would even take a
longer story just for them to tend to
that more um and still have that
expiration very nice very
nice next up to
bat all right so I was kind of thinking
of what Conrad just had said and it
really made me think that I I like the
tears of the Kingdom story but it feels
like between each part of it there was
so much in between that was not Story
related at all it's like okay you get
say a tears memory or something else and
then you don't get any story for two
hours because you went and built a house
or explore the depths or I don't
know help the band get back together
and that type of thing so it's kind of
like and not to mention they were kind
of out of order too sometimes I I did
not do them in order in my playthrough
so sometimes it was kind of hard you
jump back in there and you're just like
wait what's happening now oh that's
right ganondorf's mad and he's gonna
take over so I like the story but it was
kind of hard to keep up with it
sometimes and the the the it was just a
lot of time in
between uh the story points on there and
that why it was a little difficult
sometimes uh for that but with closing
thoughts is now I know that we're
probably gez five years away from
whatever next Mainline Zelda game is
coming so but I am super excited to see
what's next in there it's like are we
going to be getting any type of remakes
like links Awakening are we getting some
ports for the switch or the super switch
or whatever they're they're going to be
calling it there you Swit advanc switch
super switch Advanced with Bowers Fury
yes so you know what are we going to get
next what about uh spin-offs is there
going to be another hyru Warriors is
going to be a Cadence of hyru so while
the mainland line Zelda is probably
sometime off I am just super excited to
see uh what's next what where we going
to go next and just outside of that in
general just very happy to
um be a part of this conversation with
four awesome people and to be a big part
of the Zelda community in general so
just wanted to thank you so much for
having me on and um it's a blast so
thank you thank you yeah thank you for
being here all right guys bring us home
all right so I saw a comment like oh the
loud guy wants to go last so how about I
don't go last and not be loud maybe
cat's the loud
guy is reading you guys all right y'all
be careful I'm just kidding like when
people say I don't read chat anyways the
what I want to say in terms of closing
arguments is that tears of the kingdom
is indeed in my in my subjective opinion
a great game a stellar game and indeed a
an amazing Zelda game I feel that a lot
of complaints when it comes to the
legend of Z of K and breath of the wild
that came before it uh a lot of them are
valid a lot of them are hyperfocused on
one aspect that goes into people's own
selective bias and that is what Zelda
has been plagued with ever since the
beginning and like that is not up for
debate people can have their own like
interpretations of how Zelda was
received in terms of each individual
release going through the years and I
feel that tears of the kingdom is once
again not unfairly because it's
something that happens like with every
Zelda game not unfairly but it is being
cool for reasons I feel that have esing
levels of validity I will say this uh
throughout all of it when it comes to
the idea of the story and because we
don't have a lot of time I'm not going
to go way too in depth into it if like
anyone wants to talk to me in depth
about this that fine but when it comes
to the
idea of the Legend of Zelda's story I am
not discounting the idea that these
games have strong stories that the story
is important to fans and that it they it
should feel important to fans
100% but and here's a very big but is
that the Legend of Zelda in terms of its
story when it's being crafted by those
that are creating the games with the
exception of Skyward Sword have always
been an afterthought and there are
countless interviews that support report
that and we are seeing that more so than
ever with breath of wild and tear of the
Kingdom especially when it comes to the
whole timeline debate which probably
will never be answered unless they
decide to do creating a champion but for
tear of the kingdom and there are many
unanswered questions that we've seen
throughout Zelda not only in tears of
the kingdom when it comes to where did
this go what happened to that that were
explained afterwards to varying levels
of acceptance with that being said I had
a blast with this stream and it was good
to like you know get my perspective out
on the LED of Zelda tears of the Kingdom
breath of the wild with varying
differentiating opinions which I feel
are all still extremely valid with
amazing Zelda content creators that are
here with us
today I'm G to cry but no no no it's
been awesome having you on uh it's been
awesome having each of you on uh Mr
Conrad yeah I want to thank you for
extending the time because it was
definitely necessary to get the full
picture yeah that's me that's on me of
it all so uh I I thank you for the
opportunity as well what I would like
just to say is that um we are in a very
interesting spot with Zelda now because
it just feels like I hate to say it but
the F fan base has become very divided
yeah bre the wild divided the fan base
uh into like old school and new school
and then people got even more divided as
a result of Tears of the Kingdom uh many
didn't like the whole division of the
layers and how connected they were and
balancing uh issues of those uh and I
think like some people felt like okay
the amount we had in tears of the in bre
the wild was fine we we don't need much
more because it just gets too
overwhelming and I think the Zelda team
has a lot to think about now to see how
can we compromise it's very much like in
the situation of Smash remember with uh
the melee Community being melee is the
best game there's no other game they
exactly and then uh Kingdom Hearts 2 is
the best Kingdom Hearts game there is no
other game exactly and I think we're
very much in a situation like that where
I think they have to look at how do we
combine the present and the past in the
best possible way uh in the future
seeing that we can take the best
elements of the open air but also uh
combine that with or fuse it with uh the
elements that uh we know and love
uh from uh the best rated games uh in in
Zelda's past I I think that is where the
solution lies for this franchise and
it's not tied to just specific items
that are missing and so on no it's just
the structural the overarching things
that keep us immersed keep us in high
rule instead of losing attention and
then suddenly oh no I'm surrounded by
the real world again that is what we
need to obtain and gain back from The
Legend of Zelda it has to be an
experience where we don't feel like we
have to stop a moment and get pull out
pulled out of the game we want to be in
high rule nonstop that is what the
Legend of Zelda should be and I hope
it's going to be like this uh as we
enter the uh the 40th anniversary of
this franchise 40 wow well anyway guys
um that was fantastic thank you all so
much for being here um and I hope that
you did enjoy uh your time talking with
each other talking with me about the
game I think that honestly we just need
to do this again at some point like
there are there's so much here yeah here
and you say that like 30 minutes per
group I'm like bro you can you can tell
right you can tell how often I've hosted
things right but no it's all learning
experience uh thank you guys so much for
being on um I'm going to go ahead and
head over to the next group now um so
I'm you did a you did a great job oh I
appreciate so much you know uh anyway so
I will talk to each of yall soon I'm
sure have a great rest of your day and
yeah all right then see you bye
bye I did not mean to do that all right
let me get the next one started you
guys give me just a second and I will
create the
call
okay
start
yeah y'all s y'all tell the creators
that you uh enjoyed seeing thank you in
the chat because I'm sure they are
looking okay we've got
nendo we've
got
okay I believe this is the
next complete
group now hopefully hey
there
hello can everyone hear me yes can you
hear me yes yes we can we sure can I'm
so sorry about taking a much longer guys
that is on me I gave each of these
groups 30 minutes ah I'm dumb big dumb
especially with such a such a subject
right it's a big subject a lot of people
have a lot of thoughts but anyway so I'm
going to go around and we're going to
have everybody just uh introduce
yourselves um so let's let's start off
with Mr Andre's restart Andre ra my bad
restart on the top left oh good man go
for it yeah no man thanks for having me
it's been a while since we gotten a
chance to talk but uh it has yeah I'm
excited to come on and you know I this
is just like a personal thing right but
like you know I'm a Nintendo YouTuber
right I'm not just a Zelda YouTuber but
Zelda is my favorite franchise and so I
get to work with a lot of other fellow
Nintendo YouTubers but I'm kind of
excited like oh okay sick I actually get
to participate in a Zelda YouTuber
discussion so thank you for having me um
but just listening to everyone um in the
last hour right like um that's no shade
by the way actually glad that you
extended it because I really wanted to
hear everyone's opinion um I'm already
I'm already geared up to talk Zelda like
it's I think it's going to be a good
time cool cool there will be some
questions returning and some new ones
I'm sure that come on uh come out of
this um so Mr Nick tendo um Nick tendo
uh go ahead and introduce yourself I
gave you a little bit of an introduction
at the start of the stream uh but what
what are you all about uh hi I'm nendo
that's just my Discord handle um I do
have a YouTube channel I just started
recently called neckflix because I just
thought it was a funny name like Netflix
I don't know um I've only done a few
YouTube shorts so um so far but I do
plan on doing actual content um I'm only
20 so I was the only Zelda game I
remember like being excited for was like
Skyward Sword in 2011 I was only like
seven or eight that back then is kind of
crazy to think about that that's already
like 14 years ago almost um and yeah I
love Zelda I honestly do like Mario a
lot more but Mario doesn't have awesome
lore like Zelda does so I my favorite
Zelda game is linked to the past and I
just I I'm excited to be talking with
you guys today especially you uh Bandit
so oh well I'm flattered well thank you
for being on Mr Alex course it's been a
while each other I know um hello I'm
Alex I help run social media and video
content at Zelda universe as well as
zeldathon and yeah just happy to be
here yeah absolutely thank you for uh
coming and then a very very last minute
Edition the hilan how are
you hi uh I'm fine thank you it's a
pleasure to be here before actually
introducing myself I also want to uh
thank you Bandit for the opportunity I'm
honored to be with uh such an incredible
plethora of uh content creators not just
covering Zelda but Nintendo and square
and HMK case as well so uh it's quite uh
it's quite an honor thank you so much
yeah
absolutely and uh well with regards to
me I'm a long form content creator I'm
uh mainly focused on covering important
works of audiovisual media uh right now
I'm covering Final Fantasy 7 uh but I
also did uh cover Zelda in a video
analysis back when I was uh extremely
excited for tears of the kingdom when I
was analyzing uh one of the E E3
trailers uh and now I should uh be
releasing as well a smash and ff7 video
but in the future I'm definitely
covering tears of the Kingdom in some
form for sure cool fantastic so just to
change things up from the last uh group
we're going to start off with a
different question um a much more
personal question I guess um let's go
around and talk about our very general
thoughts on tears of the Kingdom did you
like it did you like certain parts and
maybe not others uh let's start with you
Nick tendo uh so I have the weirdest
perspective on this game because um it's
the first Zelda game I pre-ordered so
clearly I was excited for it and on one
hand I loved it it's a great game it's a
terrible sequel if that makes any sense
I I love the story I like what it does
with it but the continuity and it being
advertised as a sequel feels kind of
false advertising to me and I get that
it does have some references to the
previous game but it doesn't feel like
it's worth really the six years of
weight that we had um I'm not really
saying like maj's mask was great because
it only took a year because I wouldn't
wish any developers to have that crunch
time ever again but that was a direct
sequel to AAR of time but I think that
game had much more legs to stand on with
the fact that nobody knew link because
it was a whole different world with PE
of the kingdom it was always marketed as
a sequel and I thought that was a great
excuse for them to really hone in the
fact that the first game happened and I
don't think they really did that enough
you know what I mean oh I do I
definitely I mean I get what you're
saying um there was there was quite a
bit there it was a terrible sequel um I
I think that I would agree in certain
regards um I think that you know a
sequel and this is just I'm going to let
everybody go but I'm just commenting on
that a little bit um I think that one of
the biggest uh disappointments to me
personally in regards to it being a
sequel ironically is how similar it is
to breath of the wild as far as gameplay
is concerned it's very derivative and
not in a good way well yeah because
that's the thing it's like um yes we
were all expecting that like we all knew
it was going to be in the same Hyrule
but the question was where are we going
to go from here you know I don't think
anybody would have been you know 100%
excited about just doing the same
shrines in the same world of Hyrule uh
so obviously everybody was expecting
something more and they did advertise
something more and to an extent we we
did get something more but I don't think
we got $70 more if that makes sense it's
yeah and of course that's going to be
kind of a well I mean I I've said it
ever since the game released I think
that the best way to experience Tis of
the kingdom is like one of my buddies uh
his name's uh Skyler he's a he's a been
a buddy of mine for a while he actually
did not like breath of the wild um I
think he did still beat breath of the
wild but he he wasn't the biggest fan
but tears of the Kingdom oh boy that was
like he that was his bread and butter
and I I think that that's like the I'm
sorry my dog is barking over there but I
think that that's like the best way to
experience uh tears of the kingdom is on
its own anyway Andre's go for it I'm
going to mute while he's freaking out
all right um yeah some general thoughts
on tears of the Kingdom um so my general
thoughts are more positive than a than a
lot of the people a lot of a lot of the
discussion about choose of the Kingdom
um yeah and it's not that I disagree
with a lot of the criticisms I just I
think the game is such a good game that
when I see that the criticisms are like
the prevalent discussion I feel like
some people who are looking in from the
outside might have like a perspective
that this game's kind of bad but tears
of the kingdom is one of the best games
ever made and I I think most people
agree with that uh and I think you know
kind of like just thinking about it
right like I think Zelda fans have such
a high expectation of Zelda especially
when we wait such a long time that we we
really scrutinize every little bit and
we want the series to be as as good as
it can be right so and this I think this
does happen to an extent per Zelda and
we can definitely later maybe jump more
into that debate about is should this
one be more scrutinized than others um
but it kind of does happen to some
extent and I guess like getting to my
just overall thoughts on tears of the
Kingdom every time a major Zelda game is
coming I have that anticipation for a
couple years and I'm thinking oh this is
gonna be the best game ever made right I
felt that way for Twilight Princess I
felt that way for scard sword I felt
that way for breath of the wild and I
felt that way for tears of the kingdom
and every time I played each game I
personally wasn't disappointed I loved
each one each game brought me basically
to tears when I beat the game um so I I
love each of them um and when it comes
com to teers of the Kingdom I feel like
my opinion is definitely something
that's going to develop over time and I
think that's actually important when it
comes to Zelda it's not just about that
initial playthrough it's it's kind of
how we receive and revisit that game as
the years progress and I'll even say
that now I currently consider breath of
the wild to be my personal favorite
Zelda game but yeah you know that took
five to six years it took that weight
between breath T the king just to me for
me to come to that conclusion and so
it's going to be interesting for me uh
when I revisit teers of the Kingdom
especially because because we even had
an interview where anuma the you know
the producer of the series talks about
how he encourages us to try playing the
game again because we might feel
differently about the game we have like
a slightly different perspective on it
but anyways like yeah tears of the
Kingdom for me you know it delivered in
a lot of ways right there's a lot of
things I wanted them to do to address
after breath of the wild and I thought
they kind of did that um but obviously
you know there's still more they can do
um but like when I got to experience the
windfall the not the windfall the the
wind Temple right and I got to see the
boss to me that was such a big moment
because it was a little bit of bringing
back old Zelda right like the big bosses
um and even though I I love um the the
direction of breath valers of the
Kingdom because I I personally actually
do agree with the direction I think
Adventure should be the focus um it was
nice seeing them starting to try to
incorporate some of those other elements
within this open air structure so seeing
the the wind the wind dungeon I love the
boss I love the bosses in general I
loved I I loved like the um you know
just everything right including the
lightning Temple the lightning Temple
that to me felt more classic Zelda but
also I agree yeah um but I also fell in
love with the tears right the the sky
and the underground I do love the loop
they try to create there and I I mean we
can I can go on and on about the
different things I loved about the game
but I'm very high on it I actually am
very happy they brought back gendorf and
I really like the way they handled him
uh but yeah it's a fantastic game but
I'm going to let you guys talk for a
little bit oh that was a great those
those were some awesome thoughts and
that's one of the I mean you are one of
the first things that you said there is
legitimately why I I wanted to put this
together so badly um because I I I feel
that you know I feel that if people from
the outside looking in only see like the
debate going on they might think yeah
this this might not be a great game
objectively and I've like you can go
back on my channel and look it up you
know like do the research I have always
said that breath of the wild and tears
of the kingdom are objectively amazing
games and I don't think anybody can
debate that I don't think it's possible
to debate that it's it'll it it will
happen yes but anything anything that's
debatable is subjective you know do you
like this style of cooking do you like
the style of combat stuff like that
objectively there is so much to explore
and so much that you can do how can it
not be considered great right so I and
you know I've I've voiced some of my
criticisms for the game as I'm sure you
know uh so yeah I think I think that
that was one of the it was a very that
was a very good answer is what I'm
trying to say um Alex I know I know you
got some thoughts over there I know you
do um we did have a super chat question
uh so let's go and by the way um not
pointing any fingers I think someone's
mic is picking up uh the the breath um
and it's kind of just be aware of that
um anyway but we have super question oh
no worries at all no worries at all uh
Grandaddy otaku says for the panel is it
possible to say that breath of the wild
and specifically tears are great games
but not necessarily perfect games uh PS
my name is Andre 2
um and there's the super chat right
there um I'm just going toad yeah I'm
just going to go ahead and answer that
one um I think that that in and of
itself is Right debatable um I think
that the previous group we had been
talking a lot about what makes a Zelda
game is Zelda game and for there are a
lot of people out there that view tears
of the kingdom and breath of the wild as
100% awesome Zelda games and there are a
lot of people who do not uh so anyway I
think that that is debatable but the one
thing that's not is that they are great
games uh in general but anyway all right
we got that out of the way uh Mr Alex
what are your
thoughts so I had a really Rocky history
with bre the well and tears of the
Kingdom I didn't outright love breath L
wild at the start I didn't really get it
back then so as for like 3 years later
into the pandemic um I Revisited the
game and I'm like oh my goodness this
game is actually really good I'm not
sure why didn't catch similar yeah
visiting I'm telling you it's definitely
a thing yeah so when I play the game all
over again three times in fact I was
like this world's really fascinating and
I just got so invested in the world they
created in in this game so my feelings
for tears of the Kingdom were were
pre-made because of that including AE of
calamia that came out the same year it's
like oh I love this world so much like
they're going to add so much more to
tears of the kingdom and then I kind of
felt like I was left a little dry when
tears of the Kingdom came out I'm like
uh what happened to this what happened
to this uh stuff like that so but uh but
but just just to just pedal back a
little bit um I went went into the tears
of the kingdom and I was really excited
cuz this is a brand new Zelda game for
the first time in like couple years you
know
um it started off really incredible
because the first part of the game is
amazingly exciting as someone who likes
the story in Zelda like you start off
really strong with the opening like
underground finding gondorf and then
everything happens and then things kind
of get slower and slower and you know
it's just I feel like you know what I
probably should just like focus on the
gamep play and just see how it is in
that perspective and it really hits hard
with the game playay the game play is
really incredible you can tell the dev
team and anuma worked really hard on
this game from a gameplay perspective
and that's where I appreciate it a lot
the story though just kind of feel like
I missed a lot from that which I can
Delp into later but so my my my my
relationship with TS the kingdom is a
little you know Rocky it's just yeah I
liked it but I wish there was more you
know I'm kind of curious though right
because you mentioned like if at first
you didn't love breath of the wild but
when you went back to it you started to
like really appreciate it more do you
feel like there's a chance that may
happen for teers of the Kingdom uh that
ultimately depends um the while what
what breath of the wild had going for it
was not only the base game but the DLC
and the DLC really helped me enjoy the
the story a bit more because I got to
learn about these characters and if
there were if was DLC for ter Binum
where we learn more about our fellow
sages or the the or the the the
ancestors that'd be really cool but
we're not getting that according to
Aluma so multiple times yeah so yeah
yeah so it's like the extended content
helped me like enjoy the game more so
and I think and I think breath of the
wild also had uh originality in its
favor right the fact that it was a
complete
uh new approach to understanding Zelda
some people might have like that first
impression that might be you know a bit
weird to some but if you know how to
approach it you might understand what
it's trying to communicate and then uh
once you do understand that
communication it's everything starts to
feel like everything it's it makes sense
but tears of the Kingdom will forever
live with uh breath of the Shadow sorry
with breath of the wild Shadow sorry
breath of The Shadow
the next
game yeah right with breath of the wild
shadow um on its on on top of it right
because uh it would always be uh living
in its comparisons uh it's it's not
going to be uh an original a completely
original um experience and I think this
extends to how the gamepl uh was handled
and how the story uh was written in
comparison to breath of the wild a lot
of things I don't want to anticipate
made my point here but uh it definitely
uh feels like tears of the Kingdom has a
lot of uh derivation I think like it's
very derivative of breath of the wild so
it's harder for a revisit to change our
mind compared to breath of the wild I
think I think also sorry one more thing
I like I also made I think also made the
slight error in replaying a majority of
bir well just before tars of the Kingdom
came out I'm like I kind of got burnt
out really fast from playing it was like
I should have said that I I I mean I
also said the derivative thing and a lot
of people like I heard Conrad earlier
talking about that and that's true but
I'd argue Majora's Mask is incredibly
derivative but I still have it on its
own two legs compared to ocarino time
because how different it is um even
though the engine's the exact same and
one could argue it plays more similar to
Ocarina than tears of the kingdom does
to breath of the wild agreed agreed on
that with that um and that's like the
only direct sequel I can think of that's
like the same engine I mean I guess
Triforce Heroes but that doesn't really
count in my book um so that game I I I'm
always going to bring it up because it's
the closest thing that te of the kingdom
is to a Zelda game I think Majora's Mask
is to Ocarina as tears of the kingdom is
to breath and the difference though is I
find that Majora's Mask even though it
was made in like literally a year has
much more it was much more willing to be
different than Ocarina even though it
plays the exact
same yeah it's I think I think it's
derivative in the in the right spots I
think that exactly like it's it's it
maintains the mechanics uh the core
mechanics of movement how you control
link uh how the game is structured in
terms of of like dungeon map dungeon but
in terms of like the story telling
itself the the Thematic presentation
everything else it's all completely
original so I
think yeah I think it does what tears of
Kingdom failed to do in that it expanded
on Ocarina his main problems and I don't
think tears of the Kingdom did that
enough I think it did with the dungeons
even though they weren't perfect I did
like a lot of them though um it did it
with the bosses but it did not do it
with the weapon durability it did not do
it with the story and it did not do it
with the exploration in my opinion even
though I mean breath of the Wild's
exploration is amazing I felt tears of
the kingdom is very like luster I'll
give you a little bit of push back with
the weapon durability it's not that I I
disagree entirely personally the weapon
durability never never bothered me but I
do B yeah but I I do think that fuse was
incorporated in part to kind of make a
weapon durability less of a problem
because you can extend your duper
durability through fuse now I will say I
spoken to a lot of people that hated the
weapon durability and I think like fuse
doesn't seem to it was their attempt to
maybe remedy the problem um I think a
lot of people who hat the durability uh
uh element still hated it after fuse um
but I just want to say that technically
they did incorporate fuse to try Remedy
that but I also feel like they put a
Band-Aid on a wound that they made
because they made all the weapons
rusted which is kind of like I I mean I
don't mind it you know it's like I
didn't even mind the weapon durability
thing because I think it actually did
make the game better in a or not Ocarina
in breath of the wild um and I still
expected it in tears of the Kingdom but
I find like they just made it worse to
fix it I had a totally I have a totally
like off-the-wall complaint about the
fuse system that has nothing to do with
anything we're talking about I want to
hear it I don't appreciate how the
weapons look they're alled and they have
mushrooms stuck in the end bro like I'm
sorry I just it it it's the stupidest
thing to bother me but it bothers me a
little bit you know it's like you can
you can go out of your way to get even
the master sword you know like you the
master sword looks cool right it does
like obviously it's the master sword and
then now it's got these dope as hell
looking like green runes on it like what
it looks really cool but then you just
like stick something on there and every
time that you pull it out it like
transforms into that thing and it's just
weapons and then you know link walking
around with with a wooden shield with a
big old rock on it or with you know just
it it literally
literally this is the weapon design of
the game you know what I mean and the
weapon but just imagine that the
Chapstick is Rusted as hell uh so anyway
that has nothing to do with anything I
just wanted to that out there uh that it
looks a little odd and the only reason
why I brought that up is because like my
brother um is he he's a huge like grew
up same way that I did right but he kind
of he he plays a different kind of game
than I do uh we do like Zelda we we like
the older zeldas um but I kid you not
one of
his reasons for not playing tears of the
kingdom is that he's like link looks
goofy running around man and I'm like oh
I mean like I didn't necessarily think
to myself you know that that would be
something that prevents someone from
playing a game uh but you never know you
know so for some people they just don't
want to run around with mushroom
sticks are you telling me it's not
inviting yeah you're telling me you
don't mess with the master with a big
box on it dang no not yet my tech is not
there but you know I feel like I'm
scaling you know I'm getting there
remember one time where you go I this is
really quick one time when I first got
the game I fused a wooden Shield to a
zonai battery and it just it was a
useless item I
didn't so the I thought the battery
would do something for the shield and it
was just a big brick I couldn't even see
Shield surf with it just and I still
have it in my inventory I just haven't
used it that sucks by the way we have
had a couple super chats come through
they didn't have questions involved I
just wanted to say thank you to them so
anyway sorry go
on no I before move I don't know if we
were going to move on to the next
question but I didn't uh provide my
answer to the first question yet uh I
just I just wanted to no no problem I
just wanted to uh take take the
opportunity of the of the weapon design
that you guys uh brought forward here to
illustrate a of what I think of the game
uh so I guess the game seems to uh in my
opinion take a step forward but two
steps backwards in other things uh I
think that's the best way I could put uh
tears at your kingdom uh so basically I
I guess I find myself I don't know maybe
social media gives us a different
impression of how uh like how many
people actually agree with you on
certain things or not but I'm under the
impression that I'm in a small
percentage of the people who take breath
of the wild as like this s tier Zelda
experience I really think that breath of
the wild is actually fantastic I think
that even this the storytelling in it is
actually phenomenal there is a lot of
criticism that people apply to it but uh
I think that has a lot more to do with
how people experience the story between
um the long stretches of uh of
exploration versus the actual contents
of the story itself uh and I think that
despite this grandiosity from breath of
the wild I feel like tears of the
kingdom is a massive step down uh so I
feel like there are a lot of people who
try to box breath of the wild and tears
of the Kingdom together as if they're
the same kind of experience I am
vehemently against that notion I
actually think that they are designed in
very different philosophies and I think
that makes a huge difference uh for
example you go I think that I think that
the very the very notion of how to tell
their stories are Polar Opposites to
each other for example if you have a a a
nonlinear story through memories uh that
are being told in breath of the wild
this you you you basically get a notion
of Link's past and what happened to this
post-apocalyptic world through a very
organic way of understanding these
events like when you remember your uh
past you don't remember them necessarily
in a linear fashion sometimes you see
different things that bring you that
bring you these um different memories
right but here of the kingdom is trying
to be a linear story integrated in a
nonlinear world yeah so you are getting
a lot of crucial uh thought points that
are being given in in moments that ruin
the the punch lines for examp example
like um you might start the the quest
knowing where Zelda was uh until you
suddenly stumble upon a point where you
realize that uh you know Queen Sonia met
her terrible fate I don't know how many
how many how much spoilers we can uh
talk about here in
the it's been a year I think most of us
everyone here is like a hardcore like
Zelda fan right I think most most of the
viewers on on a subject like this will
be fine I think yeah so like I I feel
like these important moments like they
would hit so much harder if they would
follow a linear progression I think that
that's how uh storytelling normatively
works like there were a lot of
discussions in the previous group about
you know oh subjectively I I think this
Etc but there are certain artistic Norms
that exist regardless of how you feel
and there you of course you might value
these Norms or you don't that's fine F
yeah I understand that people have these
different opinions and you are free to
have them but I am personally somebody
who believes in the the artistic merits
of these norms and it uh strikes me as
incredibly poor uh in when you have a
story that's linear but you're trying to
still stick so hard to the notion that
oh player freedom is so important that
it doesn't matter if we have this linear
system we have to deliver them
nonlinearly so MH the problem that a lot
of people were Levering unjustly in my
opinion to breath of the wild about how
its story is too uh subtle it's too
short like the way it's it's handled it
it's hard to invest I feel like this is
much stronger the case here because even
if you uh watch the cutscenes together
in the order that you find them uh
without exploring in between just watch
back to back you will still go through a
lot of whiplash there's a lot of tone
inconsistencies between these scenes
that they are important to be
experienced in uh in the order that they
want this is precisely as well why when
you start the game uh paa actually tells
you like there is a suggestion of the
order of places you should go like this
is not something that you really got in
in breath of the wild the only thing you
got was you know oh go to kakaro Village
like at least you have some idea of the
places you have to go but the game
allows you to have that freedom but in
terms of the Kingdom it's very clear
from the dialogue that the developers
were conscious that the freedom was
actually working against its own design
and I think that that hurts it a lot
even in Dungeon design as well this idea
of open-endedness and linearity
destroyed some of the dungeon design
like the fire the fire temple is a
disgrace like if you if you have the the
moment that you remember that you have a
send it's done it's gone like yeah the
challenge is completely gone so
that D though exactly exactly so so
there comes a point where you start
asking yourself like how good the tears
of the Kingdom honor the idea of what
makes a z and I feel like breath of the
wild did a fantastic job even even if
the the dungeon the visual Direction
within the Divine beasts were very you
know similar to each other I understand
the importance of different looking
places every Everything having a lore to
itself but at least they still had a
conscious progression of puzzles where
you have to go from point A to point B
you have to fight a boss you needed to
use your head but in a way that doesn't
break the progression in terms of the
Kingdom I felt like they were so
obsessed with let giving all the the
tools to the player that they forgot the
that it is important to have limitations
like that that's pretty much my view on
the game basically I I have so much to
say about this game I'm sorry I don't
want to extent but that's basically the
general gist like I feel like that's
basically what I feel so I have go ahead
I just wanted to say I wanted to follow
up as a tears of the Kingdom Defender um
if that's all right I I don't know am I
the only one that's that's that's like
on on the high end of tear of the
Kingdom as opposed to lend hey now no
one's attacking no one's defending we're
just all a bunch of Pals well well I say
the kingdom Defender right because the
most conflicted I've been on a game
that's still out of 10 for me it's so
hard to describe yeah the thing is as a
teach of the Kingdom Defender right
everything you said I don't think is
false right like I I think we we played
the same game and I I saw the same
objective things you did um I and maybe
have received them a bit differently
right uh but I I still see the same
things you did and you know like I I do
agree to an extent um like the way the
story was handled I think it could have
been different like I I I agree with the
with the point that the story is
actually good but it's maybe not
presented in the best way I agree with
that um and wait wait wait you're
talking about breath of the wild or
tears of the Kingdom I'm talking about
tears of the Kingdom both for me because
tears of the Kingdom I never said that
the story is good by the way just
letting you know I know I'm not that
point is not is not your point right
that's just that's just just piggy
backing off of the prior group um yeah
um but that's I I think the story is
good um but I think you know it
definitely it has it's challenges the
way it's presented like you I like it's
it's a really simple thing they could
have done like they literally could have
like kept the the the glyphs the way
they were and I I feel like they're
so symbolic and vague that they could
have just given you the cutscenes in
order yeah even though it would just be
B if this was your second glyph you
experienced a second cut scene if it's
your fourth glyph you experienced a
fourth cut scene and I think that would
have been a little bit better but I
think it's interesting talk about like
out of order steroid Charing and that
not really uh fitting here because like
I remember when breath wild came out and
I heard about that they were going to do
the memories and at first I was actually
really excited about that because I'm a
pul fiction fan right like I I I love
pul fiction and it it's maybe one of the
best ways to tell a story out of order
and so that's what I kind of thought
they were going for with breath of the
wild and but after you know but After
experiencing breath of the wild I don't
think they did a great job of it um but
you know something um that I think is
interesting about like tears of the
Kingdom because I think there's a lot of
things that they made improvements on I
feel like the the dialogue uh the voice
acting and just the overall scripting of
the cutscenes in tears of the Kingdom on
on their own individual part right if
you want to argue that the connects
between them there's some issues there
that's a whole other discussion but like
each individual cut scene in tears of
the Kingdom I think has an overall
better presentation and quality than
we yeah I even though tears of the
Kingdom so I only have a few minutes so
I'm G have to leave the stream soon
unfortunately so I just wanted to say a
couple things um I love every Zelda game
like there's none that I don't like
breath of the wild is my favorite 3D
Zelda game tears of the kingdom is my
least favorite 3D Zelda game but that
doesn't mean it's bad at all it's still
like a nine out of 10 to me um I don't
think a lot of people have that opinion
but I will still stand by this that the
first 20 minutes of Tears of the kingdom
is my favorite Zelda intro because
that's the Lincoln Zelda that you played
as in the first game or not Zelda but
you know what I mean that you met in the
first game you got to know them and is
before I found out that nobody remembers
you so just having those two that do
have the history from the first game and
this new game doesn't reccon their
history at least um It's So Co seeing
kind of actually in the beginning before
in the beginning before rwu and all that
it doesn't really so I was I was like
this is so cool seeing these characters
doing something without a threat yet yet
a threat and just having a new story
with them I definitely really wish that
Zelda was more of an active role in this
story her existence was but she wasn't
if that makes sense um hey I'm not sure
how much time you have um I have about
two minutes okay well we do have a super
chat question that just came through if
you want to have a little bit of
priority in answering that since I know
you're about to head out um problem
we've got RJ saying no Triforce lore is
What Hurts the Most for me especially
when malice Chic attch and zonai Magic
could have been so perfect for power
wisdom and courage what is each of
y'all's biggest L let downs and we're
going to go uh starting with you and
we'll each get a turn on this one so L
let Downs lore let Downs well when it
comes to just being connected to breath
of the wild I don't like the argument
that the sh that the tech um served its
purpose because it served its purpose
10,000 years ago and it didn't
disappear and it was just buried away um
I think the easiest way to just make it
work in tears of the kingdom is have the
destroyed remnants of shik tech at the
depths that's the easiest thing they
could have done and it would have been
perfect um Lord let down in general
would be the lack of any Triforce stuff
because I agree the malice shik Tech and
zonai stuff is like amazing for the
Trinity um especially because breath of
the wild does reference the Triforce
with Zelda's light Powers tears the
kingdom does not at all it just kind of
retcons it into being her um rewind
ability Dragon her yeah that's basically
so yeah in general I and also I hate
what te of the Kingdom means for their
timeline I don't even want to get into
that because a lot of the actual stuff
that happens in the past in tears of the
Kingdom literally undoes what happens in
breath of the wild but it doesn't really
talk about that
um sorry sorry go ahead go ahead um the
first thing that comes to mind for me is
the shrines um the shrines wouldn't
exist in the past and tears of the
Kingdom I get that that makes sense but
if you look in the actual like I mean
like the Chica shrines sorry I should
have specified but if you look in the
past um cut scenes or memories or
whatever in tears of the Kingdom the
zonai shrines are there which makes no
sense because breath of the wild they
would have been there then is that you
know what I mean it yeah so but the
cloud barrier no I'm just kidding uh the
now the the in an interview which is
very it's very odd that these days we
get Zelda lore from interviews I know
but it's just kind of what's Happening
Now um but yeah that says a lot that
says a lot actually about how how the
game delivered thear actually we have to
have through extra nties to actually
understand the game instead of how it
always was before so yeah it was kind of
similar with breath of the wild with the
creating a champion um but I was going
to say uh uh apparently the lore behind
that is that um there is a shrine
created and and you might already know
this but there's a shrine created in
every spot where uh Sonia and raru have
defeated a demon and Shrine sits there
just in that swirl of green light
um is just expelling the evil um and so
they that that's the lore behind that
they went around but you're absolutely
right why where are they in breath of
the wild right like even if they're not
I understand if they're not active yet
because the events of tears of Kingdom's
intro didn't happen but it should be the
same as like the shrines and the
memories of breath of the wild where
they're inactive but they're still
sitting there you know no you're Absol
it's just it's just a tall Rock I
mean it is and and at this we're at the
point to where all of the Jon answers to
explain it away Allah shik Tech Thanos
snaps out of existence you know like at
this point I would not be surprised if
it was like the zitech snapped out and
then back in because of
XY the thing is we're at the oh I keep
hitting my Mac the thing is we're at the
point now to where it's like that's just
I know I am abusing this thing live uh
but we're at the point now to where like
nobody really cares about that you know
it's like okay yeah tell me tell me what
else you know happened that just snapped
all this in and out of existence cool
and at the end of the day it doesn't
really matter yeah well anyway I I do
unfortunately got to go because I have
work for capitalism tell people one more
time what your channel is and then you
can go ahead and head out uh yeah I have
two channels but I'm just going to link
my gaming channel um it's called
neckflix it's with a K there's no C in
it so it's n i k f l iix I only have a
couple YouTube shorts uploaded now but
I'm working on a big retrospective of
the first Super Mario Brothers game and
I hope you guys watch fantastic thank
you so much for being on man have a good
time at work great great I won't but
thank you great to meet you guys take
care uh Mr Alex um I feel like you have
been particularly quiet uh so let's
let's throw this to you what is your
biggest lore let down of Tears of the
Kingdom yeah I just should want to
interrupt anybody talking because
everyone's cooking really good stuff
everybody's just cooking smells
awesome so yeah I think I have to Echo
the same thing about the Triforce cuz
but honestly we haven't seen that
actively involved with with the with the
wild era anyway except for when Zelda
does something with their powers but
that still kind of like goes under the
radar but um the other thing that I kind
of wanted more was like the the history
and like the like the the like the the
essence of what minu told us about
dronification and like how that plays a
part in their and amongst their their
people and like clearly it's happened
before because it's been forbidden for a
reason and like she's given us the lur
here like I want more I want more not
much like well and the elephant in the
room is we've been seeing these
mysterious uh dragons in the sky since
breath of the wild and like I feel like
those are three giant dragon sized
elephants in the room so who are they
right you know like who who is Den roll
fos faros whatever and
and you know I always pronounce them
wrong which is why I was like well their
names changed yeah I made a crack I made
a crack Theory and I wish it got talked
about more because I feel like we don't
talk about is it the
goddesses no I'm thinking well maybe I
don't know but it's like I was reading
the descriptions about each of the
dragons and tears of the Kingdom cuz
that's the only place I'm going to get
information about this these characters
and these these uh creatures and I
remember reading each of them like they
are a protector or a guardian of
something and I'm thinking what could
they be protecting or guarding and I I
told my fellow people at Zu in a at Taco
Bell one day I was thinking like what if
they're protecting a piece of the
Triforce and I'm like maybe but at this
point no one
cares I mean like I I like it anything
that would bring the Triforce back to be
honest
um I'm going to quickly interject mine
and then we'll we'll get to you guys um
my biggest uh L so like a lot of my
issues with tears of the kingdom
are you know I I'm I'm one of the old
fans right so a lot of them are based on
like how it changed the franchise um I
like a lot of what they brought all all
of my rant videos right there's there
are plenty of things that I that I like
about tears of the Kingdom but one of
the things that I find it very hard to
forgive are just the the various changes
uh to the lore of the franchise and in
my opinion that's the entire reason it's
in the same franchise if you know like
if we're if we're just operating based
off of different rules every game that
comes out then why why is it still a
Legend of Zelda game lorewise you know
what I mean in Universe wise not talking
about like well it's got the best darn
puzzles out there I'm talking about like
the Triforce has always been for
instance a literal physical Relic that
can literally be broken like a Dorito
chip for instance if you know people
need to hide it away from you know the
powers that be whatever uh and when it
is broken uh and I mean legitimately the
individual pieces can be broken but when
they're separated they can each you know
be be implanted right into people for
safekeeping whatever we all know this
about the Triforce it's been a thing
since Zelda 2 when the Triforce began
appearing on Link's hand even though
that was for a different reason uh that
concept existed all throughout the
franchise the master sword for instance
the Ganondorf was superpowered by the
Triforce in Twilight Princess and
nothing could kill this man except for
the master sword right so it's like the
master sword is this ultimate power the
Triforce is this ultimate power but then
breath of the wild comes out and the
master sword is a like rechargeable
flashlight um that just breaks and then
you got to recharge it again and then
the Triforce itself in the first place
where is it we don't know in the second
place a lot of people say oh it's in
Zelda
now you hear that silence
that's that it's it's it's like what do
you mean it's in Zelda it's and they're
like that's yeah yeah yeah that's it's
in Zelda yeah it's what gives her uh
Powers Yeah Yeah Yeah Yeah well I mean I
don't I don't so actually right I just
thought you were going to continue going
so that's why I didn't say anything but
uh you know and yeah I it it's again you
know a lot of things you think you guys
bring up I don't necessarily disagree
with right it just maybe doesn't bother
me as much right yeah of course and like
for me Zelda games when it comes to the
story The theorizing it's always like a
puzzle or let's let let me even call it
like an impossible puzzle so for me it's
always fun and I personally enjoy like
um considering different perspectives
right like so like you know I might talk
about one Theory and then two weeks
later I'll talk about another theory
that's entirely contradictory to the
first Theory right like and for me it's
just kind of like going through
different scenarios and finding what
maybe best fits and so for me that
that's just what what's fun about it
right so like when I see too absolutely
yeah and but I guess for me right when I
see like a a plot hole right for me
that's just all right well how can we
make it fit right and so but I guess
maybe the problem is that maybe for too
many people it's too hard to make it fit
right like you have to do a lot of pole
well for instance the the shik tech
right if it's
too okay you know let's use a different
example what about just Ganondorf just
Ganondorf in general sure uh being the
Enigma that he is in tears of the
Kingdom just hating the good guys cuz he
hates the good guys um which is which is
literally about all we know about him if
they had given I'll argue um I made a
little video about um gondorf in tears
of the Kingdom right and now this also
extends into my theory that a theory not
the necessarily the answer that this is
the first Ganondorf right but I like I
look at Ganondorf right and I I think
you do want to pull from like the other
ganondorfs well the one Ganondorf and
then there was like the the one top
there was the four SS Adventures gorf
which nobody really talks about yeah but
uh it I I think a lot of like just like
speaking on like Gand dorf I feel like
also he had um kotake and K in Te of K
which I thought was interesting and I I
kind of just there right they're just
there like so I if there's just for the
record for a low let down not see he
seeing more from them I would have
wanted to see more from them Ganondorf
gudo his surrogate mother's question
mark all that stuff absolutely I love
the I love thinking that they are the
same kotak and K before AAR time like to
me that's the most exciting and so like
yeah there's a crackpot Theory um that
myself and my buddy ran who's going to
be on to the next group who by the way
we're going to have to wrap up for and I
know that youve been waiting there the
hen uh so let's let's get through this
real quick um but a crackpot theory that
myself and my buddy came up with was
that um kotake and Kum uh create
ganondorfs and uh you know that that's
what they do uh through dark powers and
that's also that could explain his ears
being different that could explain him
already having you know like a yeah yeah
right and so that could also explain why
they look younger there cuz maybe that
maybe that that flashback is actually
before the ocarine of time Ganondorf
anyway so it I I thing is I love that
right because um I mean there's there's
there's there's a very there's different
ways you can interpret things right but
just from this perspective like I like
thinking of them just a younger versions
right before we see AAR time and then
yeah like maybe you're right like it's
just a maybe a clone or it's just
another reincarnation that they were
like all right this is the next meal
let's let's make let's let's right
that's
exactly
the 100y year creation or I'm sorry the
100y year existence of a male Heir in
the gudo and why it also stopped after
uh the last Ganondorf um according to
creating a champion but anyway I'm going
to stop that subject right there and
we're going to let the hen talk about
the lore let down then we're going to
come back to you then we're going to do
outros sorry guys this is my own fault
but anyway the hen what is your L let
down well that's actually a hard
question to answer uh I I'm not exactly
sure how I can so I I would I would
say um okay uh I think I think I would
have to give some context to this
because uh some people I'm not exactly
sure how many people share this view
about the series but uh one of the
things that I've always admired about
the Legend of Zelda was how it handled
uh in terms of writing uh time travel in
the series uh the the very timeline how
it exists I know that it's obviously
prone to discussions a lot of people
don't agree on how the timeline looks
some people think everything is the same
Legend still I don't know how people
think that but there are still a bunch
of people who think it's all the same
Legend uh but one of the most important
moments in the series was when in
ocarine of Time Zelda s Link to the Past
right so because of that decision that
character driven moment that defines
Princess Zelda as a character and
allowing link to live years of happiness
that he lost uh that brought
consequences to her and the world right
so there there was a lot of problems
there were there were consequences to
these decisions through time travel
right so every time there is a
significant change uh in the past uh
there is always a branch off from that
like there to it has to respect this
rule for acarina of times story to have
its gravitas moving forward that's why
it's a series so Zelda was always
writing in linear fashion okay uh now
with tears of the kingdom it seems to me
like they really didn't give a crap
about how time Mechanics Work in The
Legend of Zelda so a lot of people here
were saying how amazing the opening is
and I agree I don't want to sound all
negative about the game by the way I
know I've been saying negative things
all the all the time here but uh the
opening had a fantastic um tone it was
epic and everything uh and I was right
on track with that as well but the thing
that really caught me off guard was how
it it played into the cyclical nature of
time travel instead of the linear way
that it always were so basically it was
always meant to be that Zelda would be
sent to the past and that link would be
in the future and somehow
this was never a thing in the series
before but the person in the future can
interact with somebody from the past
because the master sword wield itself a
gate to be sent to the Future sorry to
the Past uh link giving zeld the the the
sword to her to heal it so it's it seems
very arbitrary the way that time travel
was written inters of the kingdom is uh
kind of it's a subdued aspect of the
lore I recognize but it's also a thing
that affects past games directly because
if time can be cyclical this way then
Zelda's decision in aaring of time loses
its strength in my opinion so uh it it
has to have a purpose it has to have a
meaning behind these uh time trials so I
think that Zelda always being meant to
be in the past and doing all these
things uh it it should have had the
twist kind of like Skyward Sword with
the whole false prophecy you know like
the past was different but they created
this Legend So that eventually they
could change the past and create a new
future that's how the series was the the
story was built up from so uh I think my
biggest let down was basically this they
introduced time travel in a story like
this where I think it didn't need to and
the the way they introduced it in the
story doesn't make sense with what uh
happened prior so yeah I think that's
the biggest one for me maybe I don't
know if it's uh clear to you guys I
don't know if it's confusing but uh if
you have any questions I can try to
answer no that was good um we are
unfortunately on time so let's go over
to you Andre and then we'll do
outros sure um what point are we
speaking on just U the whole you didn't
have a chance to say did I kind right
like um so I'll
say you know I kind of questioned why
like why do we have to have a topic
where it's just talking about our
letdowns of the lore right um you're
right you're right this was a I believe
this was a super chat question no and
it's not a bad question just for the
record right well I I tell you what go
ahead and do um your letdown and then
maybe your favorite addition to the lore
and then we'll do
outros okay right um you know I I'll
just um I'll go back to the to the kotak
I said K but you I think you like K how
how do we pronounce k I had just say KO
because people do me all the time yeah
for my pronunciations but on their names
specifically they are just like that is
just how you pronounce the uh Katakana
used to spell their name it's
coou so I just say Co that makes sense
when I was a kid I said c so there's
that oh man I I so like um it's funny
because I live in Miami right and so
there's a part of Miami that's called um
haia and so like kyia as a kid I used to
pronounce it as like kyia
yeah yeah yeah nice yeah it's it's not
it's not how I see it now but it's just
kind of funny um but yeah you know I
I'll actually I'll stick with that with
that lore let down um just wanting to
see more um for certain characters that
we didn't get and I I'll kind of extend
that a little bit uh the the one story
thing that I'll actually like kind of
agree um is bad is the retelling of the
imprisoning war several times Demon King
secret Stone secret Stone demon king
sorry go on yeah no but exactly I I that
feels like such a missed opportunity to
have had like a unique cutscene that was
relevant to each region right like maybe
we could have gotone a flashback that
kind of gave us a little bit more um
context of maybe the internal struggle
in the gudo region between like the good
guto and the guto that were following
gorf that would have been really cool
right or maybe for Theo maybe we could
have gone some extra lore on you know
the the the giant what's the name of the
boat the the ark um that was you know
the
wind yeah the wind Temple right but like
it's supposed to be like a part of their
history right so it would have may been
cool if we saw like the some more
context on that in the past and so that
feels like a little bit of a missed
opportunity um basically you know I
wanted more story right I wanted to fill
in some of more of those
gaps all right so let's go ahead and
just do outros uh we are at 2 minutes
over so where can we find more of you Mr
Andre yeah um Andre restart uh I talk
about Nintendo every day um it's mostly
I mean it's a combination of news and
theories right right now there's like
not a lot of new Nintendo games so it's
more kind of like investigative work oh
when switch 2 coming out right are we
GNA find the Symmetry Prime for stuff
like that but uh yeah it's what I do
awesome awesome and where can we see
more of you Mr
Alex you can see me at Twitter Signa
Alex or you can see me post things on
Zelda Universe on Twitter Facebook
YouTube and then zon at
zon fantastic and finally the hilan
making your debut on the channel where
can we see more of
you yeah uh you can find me here at uh
on YouTube the hilan you can search uh
for me and a living Legacy with my
series on Final Fantasy 7 and uh just
going to release now Super Smash
Brothers video and you can find me as
well uh on Twitter with the handle the
high
64 fantastic guys thank you all so much
for being on seriously I enjoyed I'm not
going to say if I enjoyed one group more
than another but I enjoyed uh I just
enjoyed this a lot this was a lot of
very good conversation thank you for
sure thanks for having us thank you very
much and I'll see you all around enjoy
yeah see you man see you
around all right guys let me get the
next group going
Hey look it's only four minutes past
we're fine we're great we're great we're
doing we're doing
phenomenally all right so let us go
ahead and
do let me see what the next group is
like I said this one is a group that I
very excited for we've got monster maze
we've got my buddy ran we've
got got Zelda lore and I hope
everybody's still good I I was trying to
like you might have seen me glancing
over there a little bit I was trying to
get people uh inform people that we were
going a little bit
over anyway okay so here is the group
DM
[Music]
video
okay hello there hello oh my god look
who it
is hello hello how are you doing okay so
let's see we've got cameras on for Mr Ma
I'm hearing double you're hearing double
on me or or on me no no that's just on
my end I had the stream running in the
background oh there you go I was like I
thought I fixed
it and I think we are waiting no you
totally Zelda lore um but no I'm here
yes the camera is not loading for some
reason oh I see I see discord's little
dots had me confused um so I think we're
all here I think I think we're all here
so awesome let's go ahead and get some
intros out of the way um everybody
should if you've been on the channel for
a while you should know Monster maze uh
we've done quite a bit together but Mr
monster maze who are you what do you all
about uh I am Don AKA monster Maze and I
make Zelda videos predominantly here on
YouTube so yeah that's about it there it
is I'm trying to branch shout still but
I I haven't I haven't decided the uh the
the direction just yet maybe Elden ring
DLC will uh say you're waiting on that
Elden ring DLC same as me I know yeah of
course of course all right going in
order luran
historian who are you what are you
about all right so uh hello everyone my
name is Lan historian um I've gone by a
bunch of other names in the past uh I
previously had
um a YouTube channel not that it got off
the ground very very much but it was TTL
madora um I've since just rebranded to
myself
um but yeah I do translations I
do
um theories lots and lots of theories uh
lots of debates lots of discussions um I
know a lot of a lot of our friends here
I've I've interacted with mulp of our
friends here today um and yeah I've I've
been a fan for a long time and I'm happy
to be here yeah and correct me if I'm
wrong but I have heard your name just
whispered amongst the elite for like a
long time as being behind a lot of some
pretty big theories out there right um I
think you helped uh with um of course
I'm not I'm not trying to oust anybody
if it but I don't I think credit is a
good thing right I think you had a hand
in like some Nintendo black crisis
videos am I correct right right cool so
very cool awesome to have you on ran hi
sir hi you're on the channel I how does
that feel weird now you he's you've you
guys have probably heard his name quite
a bit um we've we've done a lot of
videos together one of the most popular
videos on the channel uh the second
sword video was
crafted really not primar like yeah
pretty much primarily uh between uh ran
and myself um so he's a he's a huge W um
but go ahead and introduce yourself sir
I'm ran also known as lanlan historian
I'm Bandit's Discord mod over in The
Hideout where I stand there and make fun
of people all day but not really uh
really well depends on who you ask I
guess but um I've been embroiled in the
uh Zelda Warfare trenches since I was
about 12 back on the old Zelda wikis and
well before the Zelda wikies on Zelda
universe and zelda.com
Zelda power you name it I was there
reading theories learning them and now I
pester Bandit whenever I get an idea and
here we
are and hey I'm here for it and now
finally last but definitely not least Mr
Zelda lore um I for one have had a ball
uh just keeping up with your takes on
Twitter um we we seem to have a lot of
similar thoughts about a lot of things
um but go ahead and let us know what you
are all about so I'm a content creator
um that focuses on well s the lore
that's my name um and uh also theorizing
and basically talking about the lane of
Zelda it's a series that I absolutely
adore and when it comes to the stories
and the game design and the game playay
of them it's just I love talking about
them so yeah that's pretty much it cool
awesome so we're going to dive right
into it because time management is
something that I'm just terrible at uh
but I would like to just go ahead and
ask you guys what you thought of Tears
of the kingdom and let's start with you
Mr
Dawn I thought it was okay was okay what
you yeah so what what did you think
about um about its improvements over
breath of the
wild uh I think the mechanics are
definitely uh probably a nice little
like Evolution on the the the Zelda
franchise as a as a whole I I don't see
myself playing any other Zelda game in
the future and not have things like you
know Ascend and fuse and yeah it's G be
so hard going forward yeah I had that
same feeling with the paraglider and
spider wall climbing in bre to Wild I
was like how are we ever going to have
another Zelda game without that you know
it's just it's it's so freeing it's so
so awesome MH um so yeah that that part
I definitely did love
uh I'm not a big fan of the story well
that we already know that I'm not a big
fan of the story I'm not a huge fan of
the gameplay Loop and the expor the way
they handle it uh exploration in the
game I think there's a lot to improve
there
too
um especially having played other games
in the meantime just the rewards the the
the environmental
storytelling there's there's a lot to be
improved over there like for me it's a
solid seven out of 10 which is not bad
you know a seven out of 10 nowadays is
equal to trash in some people's minds
but that's just not true a seven out of
if I got a seven on my math quiz back in
the day I would jump for joy so a seven
is is is a good number a seven out of
100 no I'm just kidding a seven seven
out of 10 oh yeah of course here in
Europe we don't have A+ B plus and all
that crap we yeah we just have zero to
10 zero is you got every ad yeah yeah
yeah that's how we grade stuff nice so
nice that seems much simpler we've got a
hundred of those darn points here in the
states and you know what each one of
them are annoying um but all right uh
I'm sorry were you were you done with
that or well I was just going to say
lastly is um you know not every Zelda
game has to be a perfect 10 out of 10
sometimes I think it's healthy for a
series to do some stuff that's that
might not work in the end but you at
least you tried something new or you
tried something else and uh we'll
see where where where the formula will
be taken to next but for now um I
think it it's it's okay that that's
pretty much it's not breaking anything
right but it's yeah we'll get into more
details about all that stuff now but I
want to give the other want to give the
other a chance to talk so sure sure and
uh lauran you actually you're up next uh
for your thoughts on the game and you
also won the Super Chat Lottery hey I W
it into existence on the stream again uh
there's a Super Chat question that you
can also answer um it is do you think
the lack of item progression in dungeons
to fight bosses and get to places makes
Zelda less Zelda um so feel free to Loop
that into your thoughts if you would
like to uh but take it away okay all
right well um so I really enjoyed this
game game um I really enjoyed breath of
the wild as well in fact I've spent
probably well over 1,000 hours in breath
of the wild and at least half of that so
far in tears of the Kingdom
um there's obviously a lot of of issues
it's not perfect in any way n none of
the games have been perfect even the
ones that we have Nostalgia glasses for
like for me aine of time and the Wind
Waker Like the Wind Waker is one of my
favorites neither of them are perfect
like 11 out of 10 like no no flaws
whatsoever um but they're all still
enjoyable and they all they all hit
certain criteria and certain points in
my opinion that that make them all great
games
um so they're great despite their flaws
um with tears of the
Kingdom story progression definitely a
big one
um I I've noted that there are NPCs and
certain things that sort of help to
guide you to get the dragon tear in a
certain order especially once you get to
the Forgotten Temple they're all all the
glyphs are there in order on the wall
they're there on the map so it's like oh
so this is this is where I should go if
I want to get this this this and this
this is this is how how to get it uh
same with Pura telling link you know
you've got to go here first and then you
should go here and then go here and like
she'll say like oh you shouldn't go to
gudo Desert yet you're not really
prepared or or whatnot like if if you
were trying to just start out which is
which is great I mean the game it's
trying to be very open world very um
very easy and and explorable but also
they like there are certain things that
you kind of want to get in order but you
can do it out of order like that's
totally your choice but we suggest this
and a lot of people don't do that
because it doesn't make sense you're
going say to the hebra region well you
see a bunch of geoglyphs you're going to
get all the geoglyphs there even though
some of them if you looked at the map
are completely out of order which then
completely messes up the suspense and
the um anticipation from that story that
you're re ceing so that's the the
biggest flaw that I found in the game
um obviously there's a bunch of little
little ones here and there but I
overlook a lot of those and I still love
the story don't get me wrong yeah but
yeah story progression absolutely needs
to be if they try to do this again in
the future maybe rework that a little
bit for sure for sure all right uh ran
you are up next and you also they're I I
I think that that's just what I'm going
to do with these super chat questions is
they're just going to fall to the next
person um so how did you feel about
tears of the Kingdom also RJ has a
question if you had to shoehorn breath
of the wild SL tear of the Kingdom into
the already existing timeline how would
you do it is it an alternate well she's
is it an alternate Pocket World like
Link's Awakening or Majora's Mask the
result of a timeline convers virgins
maybe a Divine retcon how would you do
that so you're telling me out of like 10
people we've had so far I get the
timeline question hey man it's the luck
of the draw the luck of the draw man yes
and everybody's listening so you know
you know no simple if I had if I had to
shoehorn tears of the kingdom and breath
of the wild into the timeline I put them
at the end of the child timeline so far
into the future that the events of
Ocarina of Time Skyward Sword everything
have faded back into just an era of
sheer myth uh obviously you know with
the the Temple of Time being uh
memorialized as it did and the Forgotten
Temple being I think it was supposed to
be like a a shrine for pilgrimage to for
people to honor the heroes and whatnot
so with that being where it is at the
end of the child timeline it suddenly
makes sense where there's all these
different uh like pieces of armor like
the big the the Big Goron Sword and the
fierce de's mask vor's mask all that fun
stuff that's been locked away and sealed
and hidden in a vault and then stolen
then apparently gets refounded in the
depths which makes no
sense um but that's where I would put
that and then as for how I feel about uh
tears of the Kingdom I think it was
perfect but not for the same reason that
everyone else thinks it was or wasn't
years and years and years ago Mr mamoto
did an interview where he said that the
original inspiration for the Legend of
Zelda was from his time playing in the
woods near his house
his childhood and just imagining all
these creative scenarios where he's
saving a princess or fighting a dragon
and if you go into every single Zelda
game with this in mind every game is
going to be fantastic because think
about it you are
link even the name you are the link
between the character or the the story
and you that is you that is your
avatar and as you play through the game
and you know when you're playing tears
of the king and you're standing before
Ganondorf you should be seeing that from
Link's eyes to you know your sword gets
broken and you give them a little paper
cut and suddenly you're being flung Into
the Depths and all this other
Shenanigans and you're in the
sky uh so if you take that from your
eyes looking at that you're suddenly
being thrusted into this world that
you're familiar with but there's some
Shenanigans going about whether it's you
know uh what was it drugged rocks or you
know desert insect things that are
eating everything and having all kinds
of weird things going on or to what was
ever I don't remember what was happening
with Theo it's been so long since I
played that um uh blizzard yeah oh yeah
the blizzard you know yes the thing that
completely ravaged the Midwest a couple
weeks
ago yeah and I just flew out to New York
just to dodge it
typical but yeah tears of the Kingdom I
think is I mean obviously it has its
flaws but and its story is presented in
basically two sections you've got your
Zelda Story You've Got Your Sage story
and you're experiencing both sure they
messed up quite a lot on the sage area
that repeating the same story four times
then you go to the Zelda side which is
in my opinion beautiful the way they
held everything in suspense with Zelda
and if you experience the way you're
supposed to by going by following impa
impa's trail to the different
geoglyphs um it's written perfectly
because you're seeing her struggles her
trauma Sonia getting you know punched in
the back like this is melee or just the
the way they present it and then that
big reveal where she becomes a dragon
and you're suddenly gripped with the
absolute trauma that comes with oh Lord
she's been above our heads this entire
time for well over 10,000 years and she
the same what's her
fate you can't beat that there's very
few games aside from skywards sword that
capture that same traumatic essence of
oh God what's going on with Zelda we
don't know and then we find out and then
you know the whole big diving thing
where you're reaching for her hand and
you know even even though the game sells
out by not letting you guys Splat to the
ground and just reset you back up top
you know right makes me sad in other
ways but
yeah but yeah problems no no no very
very good thoughts though it's good to
focus on you know not just negative for
you
know you know not not that opinions are
wrong necessarily but it's good to just
you know refreshing to hear some just
good old love for the story in the game
but Mr zeldor how did you feel about
tears of the Kingdom oh boy Qui to
begin
uh okay uh so I'm going to divide it
into two parts I'm going to talk about
the gameplay and I'm going to talk about
the
story in terms of the story huge
disappointment um not only so this we
know that the story is divided into two
parts we've got selda story which is in
the past and we got with with the
memories and we got the main quest if
you take the story of Zelda in
isolation it works perfectly right if
you do it in order the problem comes
with the main quest and how the story in
itself is delivered because on the one
hand you you can do the story uh of the
me collect the memories out of order
which ruin the entire plot
completely um because the entire plot
revolves around the mystery of where is
Zelda you know and also wor is gond but
that's sort of like at the end um and by
getting the memories out of
order you basic or getting them
completely before you do anything of the
main quest you basically know everything
and the
story with all the characters it
basically has a big problem with
characters omitting key information that
they hold from you for the sake of the
plot com for the sake of the plot for
example in this great Sky Island um the
first character that you meet it's not R
it's um a construct the one that gives
you the
purad and it then directs you to um to
the Temple of time and he's like oh uh
we don't uh maybe you meet selda there
you know if you watch the memories that
construct saw selda become a dragon and
then it just acts like it didn't know
know everything when you talk to raru
all across the Great Sky Island at no
point that he then explain anything that
happened in the past and he's very vague
about where SEL is and everything
instead of just explaining everything to
you because you know the entire blood
revolves around the mystery and then if
link learns everything about the what
happened to to to uh Zelda he's very
selective about who he tells he tells
for example he tells impa and then she
goes to kakaro to try and figure out a
way of how to reverse the if there's any
way of reversing the reification but
then when he goes to Pura who's the key
person leading the entire investigation
or he goes to pen who's doing an
investigation around all of hyru trying
to ask questions of where she is or any
other character like the sages he just
stays silent he doesn't say anything to
them so he just completely ruins the
immersion in that regard in terms of
Ganondorf my God Ganondorf is completely
it completely ruin
Gan and I'm not and I'm talking
specifically with what's uh estblished
in breath of the wild because in breath
of the wild and creating a champion they
go in detail about what about the origin
of Calamity Ganon and they're very
explicit about it they they basically
tell us that it is ocarine of time
Ganondorf very explicitly that he was
defeated by the hero of Tam and the
Princess and the sages which included
Ruto and then he was sealed away and
over countless generations and eras he
was revived again and again and again
and fought a hero and a princess
throughout many years and then he
eventually lost control and became the
Calamity that was established so when we
got the trailer for Te of the Kingdom
the first one where we s of underground
and we saw ganando was sealed and we saw
we basically connected the dots and we
said oh my God he's underneath Haro
Castle because even R king Rome told us
that the Calamity Rose from underneath
haral Castle we saw his rounded ears and
we saw those are the ears from aarin of
tondorf this has to this is occurring of
Tam Ganondorf and then we go to tear of
the Kingdom so we go to tears of the
kingdom and then it's just
completely separated from everything
it's just it just feels like a
completely separate character when it
was not it was not set up that way and
it isn't just expectation from us fans
that saying oh goov has to be this way
because we believe it no it's something
that they set up and then just
completely disregarded and it destroys
Ganondorf as a character because
Ganondorf and it's also ties with forces
avenges that game the explanation they
gave in the book is really angers me
because it goes against what Ganondorf
is as a concept Ganondorf is the
embodiment of Grudge and his whole point
is that he refuses to stay dead no
matter if he gets killed no matter if he
gets sealed he will always come back
with a vengeance that this is something
that mamoto himself said in an interview
and I'll read it and this is um an
excerpt from har history himself and
it's direct words from Yamoto even
fantastic
yeah so even though Ganon is defeated
time and time again he's evil incarnate
and will come back time and time again
with a Vengeance each time when the
world is blanketed in evil a young boy
and a girl will be born Link's
Adventures will go on for as long as
continues to for as long as you continue
to love this world and so on so he's
very explicit about that and even
creating a champion is the same thing
they explain how Ganon the same being
returns again and again and again and
again in a cycle with no which ties to
theice and his whole his whole
deal so either with tears of the Kingdom
just completely
ignored
the basically made it so that this is a
completely new Ganondorf which
completely destroys the the whole
concept or Gan has severe case of
Amnesia one or the other um and the the
thing is the start of the game which we
can all agree is really cool right the
way that they introdu
loves the start um it teases us so hard
with basically the the the connections
to the Past because we when they reach
the the mural they mention the
imprisoning war and we instantly think
oh my God adding to the past they no way
they they're doing this they they're
connecting everything then when we reach
Ganondorf when he wakes up the first
things that he says Zelda and you who
carry the fragile sword link so in he
remembers them he knows them and with
the added lore from from birth of the
wild you know that he knows them because
he's fought them that's the whole point
and then he mentions raru and you go oh
my God they're doing this they're making
they're making the
connections and then when you get to the
sky island you see oh raru oh he's just
a goat guy oh he's the first game of
hyro nobody okay completely different
Ganondorf oh he's just a random guy uh
is he the same guy maybe maybe not
because even if in his design he has
those characteristics from the gudo of
aarin of time and then if you look at
the other gudo they have pointed ears
and green eyes but gond has the Amber
eyes and rounded ears from the gudo from
rarin of time so you could wiggle that
in and say that he steal that gun from
AAR of T and then there's the question
of what doesn't he recognize the masur
what doesn't he know of linoln Zelda
where why doesn't he have the motivation
of getting the Triforce nothing it's
just like he his wi his mind is
completely white you know yeah which is
weird if I can interject one second like
I always I always imagined Ganondorf uh
like if I had to make a comparison I
would kind of compare it to Dracula
because like uh Dracula is he works on a
kind of a similar principle he's it's
always the same guy it's always the same
uh you can kill him you can do all kinds
of stuff to him burn him to Ash but
there's always a way to bring him back
either mix his Ash with blood and he
will revive again so he's just like this
almost ageless being that just keeps on
persisting and keeps on keeps uh retains
his memories still knows everything like
thousands and thousands of years into
the future he still know it's Al it's
almost like a curse also for himself
because he's he's basically eternally
conscious in a way and uh I always felt
that like with Ganondorf that's kind of
a similar principle you know he after he
got the TR he started out as a normal
guy a moral man a thief and then because
of the tri force of power dem's curse
all that kind of stuff he was kind of
like demisa ultimate candidate yeah I
think even some of the books say that
like he's the the guy with the most
potency to carry on the demon curse uh
uh so yeah it it's always been that way
where he does it's always the same
gondorf if you see him again it's the
same guy ever since aw enough time it's
going to be the same guy sometimes he
will appear as only Ganon and I think in
in the Oracle games his mind is like
corrupted or wiped because they didn't
uh they tried to revive him through a
ritual but the ritual was altered
halfway through so he he was just this
mindless Beast with no uh and then of
course in Link Between Worlds he's been
used by Yuga Yuga like merges with him
and it becomes y Yuga Ganon which I I
also thought was a cool idea just a guy
who takes advantage of that curse to to
absorb that power for himself but yeah
Ganondorf in this game we don't really
know what who he is here he's just a guy
he's back but he doesn't remember
anything he's just another guto king
called Ganondorf once again and that's
fine if it's a standalone title I've
seen some of some people in the chat
mention that before like it's a
standalone okay fine if it's a
standalone we'll just have to deal with
that and just accept that the age of
trying to connect all the games is going
to be over um which I I think it's I
think it's a shame but if that's the way
they want to go fine well you know I
think one of the things that you and I
have talked about before has been um its
connections to breath of the wild like
its own predecessor uh because tears of
the Kingdom can never truly be a
standalone because it's supposed to be a
sequel to breath of the wild right I
mean every everybody knows that you know
let's say those two games exist in a
vacuum let's just prend it's like Zelda
un uh Zelda Universe Zelda lore just
said um ganondorf's backstory in breath
of the
wild is not the same as it is in tears
of the Kingdom mhm because in breath of
the wild yeah or is it okay we have an
or is it please please give us a
different perspective
here okay so barring creating a champion
because you're going to mention the impa
says right in in tears what impa and
Rome both say in breath of the wild and
in tears of the kingdom and also what we
get from osa's uh spirit okay so Rome
mentions that when we're gazing upon
Calamity Ganon circling around the
castle he says Calamity ganon's true
form the demon king was born into this
Kingdom but his transformation through
malice created the horror we see now
into malice yeah into well through in
Japanese into in English um either way
it's a transformation that relates
around his hatred and his Grudge like
you said it's Eternal it's always going
on um impa mentions kind of the same
thing she kind of reiterates it that uh
the history of the royal family of
Hyrule is also a history of calamy Ganon
that he's a primal evil uh he's endured
over the the ages they're always always
fighting against them herbosa mentions
that Ganon once took or once adopted the
form of a gudo in Japanese she says
something more along the lines of he was
once a
gudo so obviously that makes us think
okay Ganondorf Ganon of course that's
that's the
origin Rome also mentioned something
about the source being under Hyrule
Castle so that's the basis we have with
breath of the wild he was a
gudo
he transformed into something in some
way through malice or into
malice uh he's constantly haunted
Hyrule and he was somewhere deep below
the castle those those are the four
points that we get okay tears of the
Kingdom we're exploring under hyru
castle of course we come upon this
mummified corpse of a man and uh he
awakens and all hell breaks loose and so
then we start to get little bits and
pieces of the story so impa again later
on much later on um she mentions that
the Calamity is a transformation or a
incarnation of the Demon King's hatred
and Malice so the demon king of course
is the term that they use specifically
to refer to Ganondorf Zelda mentions
that as in the first like two minutes of
the game this figure is only ever
referred to as the Demon King it's the
same Demon King that Rome was talking
about as well um so all of it Cycles
back so we're given this information
little bits and pieces here and there
that seem to correlate to one another
the only thing that
doesn't is when we include creating a
champion now creating a champion has has
an
amazing um amazing array of resources
and information in it I love it but now
here's the thing it's just like Hyrule
Historia and just like the Zelda
encyclopedia it has Development quotes
it has concept art it has bring
development quot
later it has lots of these points that
are direct we we'll call them um
supplementary Canon that is directly
from the developers the rest of it is
written from the perspective of these
Publishers who have a lot of this
information and are making their best
guesses trying to connect it just like
we do they're basically theorists but
they have access to more resources right
off the right off the
bat um so from what they had at the time
the only information that they could
connect it to would be a kinaa of time
because that's the Ganondorf that we all
know and love at least from my in my
opinion that's the only one that they
could
really connect to because that was the
only one we knew of at the time they
didn't have information on this
particular story clearly that they gave
to these
Publishers also with any of the other
Publications if new information comes to
light in a game after or new games come
out a lot of that information ends up
getting retconed because it isn't as
fluid or dynamic as the games themselves
so we expected to get X Y and
Z meanwhile in the background they were
already like here's ABC and here's D so
it doesn't connect in that way but
that's because we and those Publishers
didn't have all of the facts we didn't
have all of the inform information we
made lots of guesses based on what we
had at the time and we didn't have this
further
information I think that there's a lot
counter
argument well I was going to say I think
that there's a lot of Truth in what you
said but I also think just and I I'll
get right to you zeldor I do I do think
that it's a very slippery slope when we
begin to Herald
only game and word of God as Canon um
you know we we've got a lot of external
media for all sorts of franchises that
are considered Canon and there are all
sorts of you know I'm talking all sorts
of franchises Five Nights at Freddy's
Star Wars um I mean you name it uh Lord
of the Rings you know and and so there
and there are a lot of maybe not Lord of
the Rings but I mean like actually yes
Lord of the Rings there it's
like what I'm trying to say is there are
always going to
be multiple hands involved in the
creation of something that could be
considered Canon you know it's like to
what if it's not the word of God from
like anuma or really an argument could
be made then maybe anuma doesn't know
because he's not the one who created it
if it's not Moto's word himself is
everything debatable as far as Canon is
concerned you know it's it's it's a
slippery slope um because on the same
you know and on the flip side we've got
breath of the wild and tears of the
kingdom and all sorts of references to
all sorts of things that are pseudo
Canon you know is that actually you know
the breach of demise over there or is
you know is that actually lawn laon
ranch or you know the the list goes on
and on there are all sorts of or or is
that actually the Major's mask sitting
in that chest right there um it's it's
debatable you know it's pseudo Canon is
the word that I use for it because it's
like you right we have to debate if it's
legitimately really happening the cannon
of breath of the wild is that link found
the Majora's Mask underneath the ruins
uh in this one River and then a few
years later he F found it he lost it and
then found it again you know in the
depths uh it's like what what is Canon
what isn't you know what I mean um so I
it to me
personally un unless I see something
that
blatantly you know
disregards basically what I'm trying to
say is I uh take established Canon more
impactfully than New Canon especially
when the new Canon might not agree with
the majority of what came before but
that's also kind of a personal thing I
think I think that that's the very
reason why what is and isn't Canon is
debatable uh but anyway that's just my
little interjection um I think zeldor
you had some thoughts directly on what
he said there actually um can I chime in
first you can you can you yeah so zeldor
you mentioned earlier that this being a
new Ganondorf would completely
destroy the whole Incarnation thing
right yeah you're going to talk about
for
aventur yes but also
no um so you are correct I am going to
talk about four Swords Adventures now
that is a different Ganondorf I mean
that is confirmed from what hold on hold
on let me get there come on now keep it
clean um but no it's it's a different
Ganondorf and if we have to use say
Historia or encycl IIA or creating a
champion for the basis of our debates
which realistically I think we should
what what do historians and
archaeologists do as they research
things they pull from any available
sources and they cross reference to
what's known so if the creators of hyal
Historia are looking at these things and
then then and then they determine that
okay this Ganondorf is a new Ganondorf
born into this tribe of all female
warriors
who more or less just let him do his
thing because they think he'll just die
in The Pyramid anyway and then that same
book also tells us that the the hatred
from Twilight Princess Ganondorf was
reborn into
darklink it sort of keeps the same
premise that we're seeing in breath of
the wild and tears of the Kingdom with
Ganondorf am I wrong because malice
ganondorf's pure hatred resulted in the
formation of darklink in for Swords
Adventures if I'm understanding that
right I could be wrong but that sort of
follows the same line of thinking that
they use for breath of the wild sure we
have a new Ganondorf but with the old
similar hatreds of the malice which
created Dark Link and Calamity Ganon it
establishes a precedent to which the
games have a footing on more or
less okay I'm going to deconstruct the
whole concept of a second gun of
existing forces Adventures with
developer
quotes So first of all the whole the
whole placement of so the whole idea of
um a second gun of existing is due to
where they plac the game in a timeline
but I generally don't understand why
they placed it there because not only
there's there's two things that I want
to point out first of all the game
itself that's very explicit in where the
the game takes place in the timeline at
the very start of the game it tells you
that it's immediately after the events
of four Swords after vat is defeated and
there is no time in between between the
two games people believe that there was
peace that had return return to hyru and
immediately after dark clouds began to
cover the clouds the Skies of hyru
leading straight to for of Adventures
it's the same link and the same Zelda in
the for sorts and for S Adventures anuma
when games uh for SS Adventures released
stated this the G the the Game Boy
Advance for Zelda is what we're thinking
as the old this taale in the Zelda
Timeline when it released so this was
before Minish Cup released and before
Skyward Sword with this one in the
GameCube for Adventures being a sequel
to that and taking place sometime after
that so in anous words this game took
place before uring of time both of them
when force was
released it was packed with adding to
the
past and gond at the end of for's
Adventures is sealed within the for
sword right m in for's Adventures the
real release they added an entire new
dungeon that included the for sword and
in that dungeon the for sword is
shattered into four pieces we know that
seals in the series never last forever
so inevitably like vti Ganon would break
fre and that game was also serves it as
a preal to into the past it serves as a
lot of um Origins to a lot of aspects um
like the
are definitely a lot of Easter eggs in
that it we meet the creators of the
bombos and quick medallions that we
later use ining to the past that which
are Mages that very specifically say we
created these
medallions and there we meet the Knights
of hyu who later die during the conflict
with Ganon the ceiling War It All Leads
up toing to the Past including the art
style it's a Perfect Blend between the
style of four Swords and alink to the
Past it's a transition in his art
style I don't believe at all that the
the gond is a second Incarnation I at
all I don't it it just goes against
everything that Gan establishes because
when even when Gan is killed in Zelda 2
and I link to the past he always ends up
Reviving if he just reincarnates into
something else at what point would he do
that because centuries pass between
incarnations between revivals and he
always just is the same guy even in in
Twilight Princess he dies several times
and he just always comes back when he
gets killed by the Mas sword By The
Sword of the sages he dies and then
revived by the Triforce when he's sent
to the Twilight real he becomes a spirit
of malice that's his second death and
then revives s says he's reborn into the
world of light then he's killed by midna
and well he's killed by link when in
Beast form he becomes the spirit again
then G kills midna and then regains his
form and then finally kill Bing with a M
sword so he dies and revives in that
game several times as well that's
basically Ganondorf as a concept he just
refuses to stay dead even in breath of
the wild when selda when Ganondorf
becomes the Calamity the like the dark
Beast Ganon and this was mistranslated
in the English version in the Japanese
version he says Ganon refuse Ganon
refuses to give up on reincarnation he
always comes
back so guys I am loving this debate on
Ganondorf I'm going to take it back to
tears of the Kingdom um and honestly
this fantastic stuff seriously um from
every single one of you uh but we're
going to take it back to tears of the
kingdom and I'm actually going to get
monster maze to chime in here because I
don't want him to fall asleep you know
I'm looking at him and I see him I see
him nodding
off I'm good I'm I'm I'm fascinated I'm
yeah when he when he comes to to car it
away no no no no seriously very good
stuff but you know I'm just going to
kind of guide it back did you have any
thoughts about that if not I'm going to
move on to the next question MH who me
yes sir oh no I was just about to say
like obviously there's a lot of timeline
stuff that we can debate and can talk
about but let's focus on the the story
as a standalone thing for a moment and
just or at the very least together with
breath of the wild because it's a
continuation so let's take that era and
just focus on that
and um there were a few super chats that
came through which were questions um but
we're steering back to tears of the
Kingdom so we're not going to get to
those at this time uh but anyway I
wanted to say uh this is another opinion
piece um what is your favorite thing
that makes a Zelda
game and then uh oh God yeah and then
I'll and then I'll contrast that with uh
what is your favorite thing about tears
of the
Kingdom yeah that's that's a one cuz
Zelda is very flexible I feel even the
name doesn't necessarily like a lot of
games have established a certain thing a
certain shtick where as long as they
stay within that it makes sense but then
suddenly you can have you cannot have a
Fallout game without uh it being po uh
post-apocalyptic you know or The Last of
Us without the
postapocalyptic what an annoying word
post-apocalyptic
yeah 10 times fast yeah oh my God but uh
like with Zelda you Zelda has done that
but it's also done the more uh quaint
fantasy kind of stuff I could easily see
a Zelda game that takes place a little
bit more more close to our technological
age uh like it's already starting to
make that step a little bit with the
shika slate and you know which is
basically an iPhone or an iPad if you uh
if you want to call it that so it's very
flexible
as a series The Legend of Zelda can mean
anything to me I agree uh it's just the
I guess the the sense of adventure is
that's always what's been for me at
least one of the main points of of uh
playing a Zelda game dungeon crawling is
a big thing for me uh meeting characters
uh that's one reason why I
think um you cannot really say this is a
Zelda game or this is not a Zelda game
uh I think in the one of the previous
groups you guys talked about that like
is Tunic a Zelda like it's like no not
really I mean it it has the the overview
and you like the overhead view and it
has a sword and he's even got a little
green outfit on but the spirit of Zelda
is very difficult to Define you know you
can copy certain like gameplay elements
from it for sure just like you can make
any game into a c like a Metro Vania
type of game mhm but with Zelda yeah
I for for me personally it's always been
the sense of adventure uh just exploring
a world and the the problem is there's a
lot of games that do that nowadays so
it's getting harder and harder to be
original in this field uh you know I
agree it it is a difficult world to
continue to innovate within yeah and
Zelda usually tries to remedy that with
new uh mechanics which
are original you know before bre the
wild there was no other game where you
could climb literally anything or at
least not that I'm aware of uh and now
you got many because now genin impact is
doing it and other Zelda or bre well
type
of inspired games are starting to do it
I think we had uh Moxy Watts had a Super
Chat come through about what games we've
been playing since uh tears of the
Kingdom released and I just had
I had to mention power world you know
it's got like 10 million sales so far
anyway I don't want to I don't want to
deviate too much um but let me let me
edit because I was going to ask uh I was
going to have you contrast that with
tears of the Kingdom
but going forward right the future of
Zelda it's something that everybody's
thinking about these
days how would you how would you craft
like the perfect most ideal Zelda
because like back in the day right when
I it me person what I consider the
Golden Era of Zelda has nothing to do
with sales obviously objectively it's
right now because like breath of the
wild alone has over 30 million uh units
sold TI of the Kingdom uh raced up to I
don't know what it was 13 or 14 and then
it kind of plateaued um but uh yeah I
mean the point sales numbers I hate
sales numbers in general exactly exactly
but using that as a any comparison
doesn't make any sense because it's it's
it's uh it depends on so many things the
success of the conso it's on whether
it's crossplatform or not you know that
also makes a big difference if your game
is available on five systems obviously
you have a much bigger of the wild had a
bunch of well it was released on two
systems right and tears of the kingdom
was released on only one and so yeah
there's there's a lot of nuances there
like you were saying um but to me as far
as like the the Holy Trinity of like
story and gamepl and impact you know to
to to me personally is what I call the
golden ER of Zelda and it would have
been like Ocarina to Twilight you know
like Ocarina Majora Wind Waker um you
know Twilight Princess I loved all like
any of those games can can be my
favorite just depending on when you're
talking to me right but yeah the way
that I view Zelda games back in those
days was 90% like story
Innovation and just hand
Concepts that I just never thought about
and like 10% gameplay Innovation cuz
really once they set the new presid from
like aine of time and 3D zeldas they
didn't really I mean like Wind Waker had
a big ocean right exploration but I'm
talking about like legitimate new
gameplay elements um but these days it
does feel like it is flipped it feels
like it's 90% gameplay Innovation and
10% story Innovation I mean as as
Innovative as they as they were or the
biggest thing they did with the story
was they were like boom It All Happened
100 years ago plus piece it together in
a nonlinear way have fun um but what
what do you think do you think that it's
possible to have a 5050 split in the
future I think so yeah I don't see how a
story can ever get in the way of game
playay I I just don't and if you if they
if the Zelda team generally like
genuinely is convinced that it is then
they're just wrong they there CU there's
games who've done it better there there
are games who plus they know that they
have a very wide fan base you know and
not every fan base will have um I've
talked about this before it's like you
have these different groups within a fan
base who play a game uh you have the
speedrunners you have the uh the lore
enthusiasts you have whatever you know
you have all these groups usually the
ones who are the most voted are also the
most Niche CU most people don't speedrun
bre to Wilder tears of the Kingdom most
people
don't like out of those millions of uh
sales that they had there most of those
people who play that game will just play
the game enjoy it move on to the next
game you know and usually it's the
speedrunning community the lore
Community those kinds of communities are
the ones who keep the game alive for
many many years to come uh glitch
Hunters uh all that kind of stuff
modders obviously even though the story
yeah it has nothing to do with the story
necessarily but you know I've had I've
gotten so many comments of people saying
stuff like you genuinely made me more
hyped for for tears of the Kingdom over
the years uh and I actually got into
Zelda and into the lore more because of
channels like your uh like yours and
Bandit games and all you know all of us
zeltic obviously mhm uh you know so they
they know they have a big group of
people who are very very interested in
the lore and why not try to satisfy all
of them you know why not try at least
try to give everyone a little piece of
what they want uh I'm not saying you
have to give them exactly what they want
because I'm also a big believer in
giving people what they didn't know they
wanted but you know tears of the Kingdom
at least for me made it very clear that
they are not interested in telling big
deep lore and stories anymore they are
mostly focused on how can we create a a
very innov uh Innovative game uh with a
lot of Unique Mechanics uh I think I I I
would not be surprised if at least a
third or maybe even more twoth thirds of
the total development time went into
creating stuff like Ultra Ultra hand and
you know Ascend and all those crazy
would Age yeah which which are very
impressive but why would you sacrifice a
story for that too because there are
ways to tell a story and give us lots of
lore to work with for many many years to
come while also having those gameplay
elements I'm I'm sure that that that's
possible and you know you can do it in a
way where the game itself doesn't get in
the way of the lore Elden ring for
example my first playthrough of Elden
ring I didn't really interact with the
lore all that much I was way too into
the game itself just try to survive
finding dungeons it's yeah it's it's
such a good game but it's only after I
finished the game that I started up
started looking up lore videos started
you know searching the world myself for
lore reading all the item description
that usually comes after so I think it
is possible and and eldering has a lot
of lore but you don't have to interact
with it and I think starting with bre
the wild they were like uh at least bre
wild still had a lot of environmental
storytelling to make up for the main
story which was very simple let's be
honest
uh but tears of the Kingdom my my
biggest issue is just why would you not
want to do more like that because one of
the biggest appealing things or the
biggest appeals of breath W for me was
all the crazy stuff you found you never
knew what was going to be behind the
next Hill and then find a you know some
huge Temple or just a little house
that's burned to the ground and there's
all these little trinkets hidden
everywhere where you can kind of you
know piece together what would have
happened there you can literally follow
every damaged guardian or broken down
Guardian all over the map and see
exactly how the great Calamity played
out you know which I've done in one of
my videos it's it's it's fascinating you
can actually great series there you can
follow the path of Destruction
throughout whole the whole of Hyrule
where all the biggest battles took place
none of that is in tears of the Kingdom
tears of the Kingdom doesn't have that a
lot of it is either nonsensical or it's
just not there The Depths are all the
same gray buildings there's nothing to
there's no story there aside from maybe
one or two but you know the it's just a
shame it's just a shame and I think they
can do it but they just chose not to for
this game and I hope they will do it for
the next game you know one one failed
opportunity not ruin a whole franchise
of course it's a stepping stone and if
there's one thing that Nintendo does
with Zelda is they they step oh hell
they step uh I will say um a couple
things real quick we
are just about out of time so what we're
going to do is we're going to go with
this question through everybody and then
we'll do outros um and I also wanted to
acknowledge to the chat that there are
some super chats coming through some
questions since we're going to do what I
just said I'm going to save these
questions for the next Group which will
come on uh anyway so uh luran uh craft
for us if you will the perfect Zelda
game okay
so um some of the things that I enjoy um
which I would love to see again in the
future is
using and and and like really
utilizing items um at like item
progression as you go um not necessarily
just like one off cuz it kind of seems
and I'd seen earlier with HMK I do kind
of agree a lot of the ones in Twilight
Princess did seem kind of one offish
like you get the Dominion Rod you use it
for like 5 seconds after the temple and
then that's pretty much it you don't
really have to use it again um but
actually utilizing items like bombs uh
claw shots things like that that you can
use to explore further or to go back and
say hey I'd seen this thing over here
but I couldn't quite get over there I
didn't know how to get up or over or
through or whatnot like besides just
climbing
um actually having something that would
be sort of item locked until you had
progressed far enough gotten that thing
and then you go back and you explore
something new in a place you'd kind of
been through before that way you're not
just constantly moving from one area to
the next and never really coming back it
kind of gives you more of an incentive
to ReDiscover or re-explore things that
you might not have gotten before yeah
it's the concept of backtracking right
and people hate on that a lot but
honestly like it works you know it can
be done very well I think yeah
absolutely it can be done it can be done
amazingly well and especially if they
have you know certain tidbits or or NPCs
or lore that you would get by going back
to those areas after you had completed X
Y or Z it actually it I would believe
that it would make you feel a little
more invested it would make you feel
more immersed uh so having that blend
back go going back to that part of the
formula and reapplying it into a future
game I also agree uh getting closer to
5050 with with uh Story versus gimmicks
and and gameplay
mechanics that's ideal even if they got
like 40 if they got 4060 or you know 20
2070 you know some at least get a little
bit
closer at least getting and aiming to
get a little closer to that sort of
middle range because that would be
perfect but just a little bit more than
what they've done I think they
definitely took a a deep
step back from focusing or or or
integrating the story uh gam play thumbs
up it's been great the story is great
just the Pres presentation definitely
has has fallen flat in my opinion um so
reintegrating and and reinvigorating
that going forward to have more story
connections more invest you know more
investing into the story and into the
character to make it feel more alive and
more immersive and having that
backtracking and that sort of item
progression so it actually feels like
you're going somewhere and you're you're
accomplishing things it's not just oh I
have more heart containers or more
stamina it's actually like I have an
arsenal of stuff and I can do a lot more
than I than I could do at the beginning
I think they have to bring that back and
that would that would help make the
perfect Zelda game that's a very classic
Zelda and I I love that answer all right
Mr
ran yes sorry I was completely
mesmerized by monster maid's completely
dead pan stare at the camera but you
know um I can do I can do better his icy
blue eyes man he does it's like piercing
right through me it's scaring me a
little but um no if I had to build my
perfect Zelda game it would be with
Ocarina of times uh item utilization in
music Twilight Princess Twilight
princess's gameplay uh Skyward Sword
story and breath of the wild scale and
scope and environmental
storytelling nice that's about all I got
for you
otherwise I love that okay can I also
quickly uh say one thing uh also uh some
maturity in the in the
storytelling that's spicy because I
don't I do think they kind of lost that
part uh just a little bit bit with the
last two games where 100% um if if I if
I may quickly like draw a comparison uh
like the the stuff that you see in Mad
mask even if it's a side quest you know
like the the Anu and Cafe qu side quest
where it's so Bittersweet and it's
relatable and it's mature it's very
mature uh cuz as a kid I didn't really
understand much what like I just wanted
the mask that that that you get at the
end of the quest but when you start to
think about more about what the actual
implication of that storyline is you
know two lovers who are basically in a
doomed world that's going to end either
way but they just want to reunite
together once again uh and they kind of
just face death together at the end but
at least they'll have each other that
kind of stuff that's not really in tears
of the Kingdom especially there's not
really that maturity to it it it almost
feels very childlike where one of the
biggest side quest is just like two
people are running for mayor and they
cannot decide if they should go with
cheese or mushroom clothing you know
that's about it like the it's it's very
childish in a way and I I think more
slapstick yeah a little bit more slapick
and I think Zelda one of the cool things
about Zelda is that children can handle
mature sto storytelling more uh gripping
stuff that makes you think because it
makes you appreciate the those games
longer as you grow older when you grow
up you will be uh you you'll be
revisiting it and you'll be able to pick
up on stuff that you know you didn't as
a kid case in point Hina and the ability
to pet dogs and the
ability oh my God that's the biggest sin
of all Mr zeldor what have you got for
us craft us a perfect game okay so in
terms of um and it ties to the question
of what makes a selda game a selda game
I view four key points um in terms of
perfect what constitutes a Zelda game so
first of all is the exploration being
able to um find secrets and and uncover
a world that you have that you're you're
exploring um the second is combat being
able to fight enemies in very cool and
interesting ways and I think Twilight
Princess excelled at the combat in every
aspect with it built upon the what of
time established and then Wind Waker
expanded on that and then Twilight
Princess really took it to the next
level in terms of um not you you could
do and when you compare it to breath of
the wild there and there's something
that I've been looking at quite recently
there's um you could do things in in the
old games like horizontal and vertical
slashes you could do uh jump attacks and
and all the stuff you could cut signs in
very specific ways that wasn't just
something that they introduced in SC
sword and in fact in Ocarina mamoto
wanted a more elaborate combat system
and then he dialed it back because he
said oh I want the game to be easier
than Mario 64 which was a really weird
uh idea but um in breath of the wild
there there's a lot of things that were
in the past games that are lacking in
terms of gameplay like there's not even
for example underwater exploration
that's something that it should have
been especially in of the Kingdom with
the the caves and and all that they
could have done submerged caves and
because they they swimming in both
Twilight princess and scabard sword felt
incredible and they have the this with
the Sora Helm you have the spinning um
maneuver that was in scabard Sword but
you can only do it on the surface and it
would make it so incredible to move um
so then of course it's the puzzles
that's the other aspect um that was
first introduced in into the past in
Sela one and Sela 2 there wasn't really
any puzzles and so it's not really the
core of of Zelda but it's a great way of
um of um coming up with interesting ways
of solving things and the way that they
introduce um items in certain dungeons
to then um solve certain puzzles and
this ties to the fourth and most
important Point progression which uh
lelan uh historian touched upon Zelda
established what we now call the
metroidvania formula or the Metro Vania
um structure yeah um because selda
really introduced The Way of the the the
whole structure of you have to get an
ability to then open up a new section of
the of the of the map or get into a new
a new dungeon or whatever um and even in
the first Zelda you needed to get all
the pieces of the Triforce to get to
Ganon you couldn't enter the final
dungeon unless you had the pie of the
Triforce in breath of the wild
everything is optional you can go to
Ganon at the start and that eliminates
any form of progression in terms of
gameplay and story or the abilities are
given to you at the start so there is no
the the gam playay progression just
stays completely St stagnant throughout
the entire experience and it gets to a
point that it's just it's boring I
didn't complete tear of the Kingdom 100%
because it just got bored and or
everything in the game it's not
rewarding the side quest they don't give
you anything what they give you a
chicken wing a couple rupees an Elixir
nothing much cor yeah no yeah but they
give you they give you like food and
stuff they don't give you anything or or
or or a piece of clothing um uh and then
the cororo as well we all know the Coro
the reward that they give you at the end
um there's not much rewarding even in
the story why do why go to the dungeons
if they don't progress anything reward
anything regarding to the story if you
can just go to the final boss and beat
the game there's no buildup in that
regard at at all not only in links uh
abilities and and strength but also in
the in the in the story since everything
everything is just built to be
completely optional and I think that
part of a reason and I did talk to you a
little bit about that in in DM's um uh
it's it's it comes down to the climbing
when you give the player the ability to
climb any surface right from the get-go
you eliminate any possibility to limit
certain areas for the sake of uh
progression for the sake of the story
for the sake of letting the player focus
on certain aspects if you introduce
climbing to games like okarina or W or
wi Waker or Majora mask TW princess SC
sword it would completely destroy the
stories and the and the and the
structure and the progression that those
games introduce by the very nature of
how it works but simultaneously you
can't also eliminate it because it feels
great to climb every aspect so what I
would do is similar to what they do with
a paraglider they don't give you the
paraglider at the start of the game
right they give it as a reward so what I
would do is have the game start
without uh climbing like in all the
games which would allow for better level
design ver puzzles but more
concrete design in general enal for the
entire world and then at some point in
the world somewhere or in the story
gained that ability to climb every
surface so you would be able to CL every
surface I can bre of the world but you
would also simultaneously have a more
elaborate world that just feels more
uh detailed like in P in past games when
I so I recently played tet princess and
I was uh exploring the the first area
right like the up to the Forest Temple
and it just it just feels so different
in the terms of how you um explore the
world you don't get to a climb and
everything I was thinking about what if
I could climb how what would happen and
in the intro for example certain things
just wouldn't be possible like um the
children wouldn't be captured at a
certain point Farm Woods wouldn't be
turned into Twilight you would be able
to go to the for steple without even
meeting midna so you would just get a
few shut out and be like okay what's
this you know there was there would be
some very key important crucial moments
of the story that would just be
eliminated there would be no sense of
progress of of motivation for link to to
just go into the adventure whatsoever so
a s restrictions are NE yeah yeah oh I
was just say and that's just talking
about lorewise you know like the
gameplay wise um there's a reason why
they remove climbing from all the
shrines in both games you know I was
going to say that too yeah yeah but it's
not just in the shrines if you notice in
in even in the kingdom uh so you know
the the snowy area right um where
there's there's a shrine at the top and
there's ice wolves and you can't climb
those because they're slippery so you
have to in be very in you have to think
of a creative way to get to the top by
cutting the trees and then sticking them
together and then Crea like a like a
like a makeshift like uh wall
essentially um another example in breath
of the wild there's a huge CM uh that's
separating you from the snowy mountain
and you have to cut down a tree to walk
past that custm which doesn't involve
climbing but it's those little things
that there are blocks in the your path
and then you have to think creatively on
how to progress and something that I
loved about the older games that it's
it's tied to this metania progression is
that when you find a block or a an area
that you can't progress that you
remember that when you get a new ability
later on you then say oh I remember that
I'm going to go back to that and then
you uncover new stuff and it's exciting
because you say oh what's going to be in
this area you know there maybe this like
a blocked cave or whatever and then and
then you go inside and say like oh my
God this so so so cool yeah that seems
to be a design philosophy they they kind
of lost over the over the course of the
the development cycle I don't know the
last P the past few years is that uh
that's probably gameplay wise that's my
biggest problem with both breath wildad
and tears of the kingdom is
uh they're both designed in a very
specific way when people say the depths
are boring for example The Depths are
repetitive they're too big they're it's
just all the same it's not necessarily
that the The Depths themselves are the
problem because the idea of the depth is
very very cool mhm but the way the game
is designed is you can drop down
anywhere inside the depths no matter
where and you will encounter
approximately the same things the same
kind of ruins the same kind of enemies
whatever happened to walking into an
area where the the enemies are so so
like far above what you're capable of
and getting your ass handed to you like
for example in the first Zelda game you
could you if you wanted to you could go
to Death Mountain right away if you know
how if you can uh uh if you know the the
the the Lost Woods puzzle you can get
there there's blue LEL there that will
well if you're still using your normal
green outfit and a normal normal Shield
that doesn't block Magic you're screwed
you're good luck fighting that you're
you're going to and in in breath of wild
and tears of the Kingdom they kind of
remove that part where the enemies scale
up with you as you progress through the
game and I hate that I I I think that's
one of the most annoying things in in
video games it's such a cheap way to
increase
difficulty like I think it's to go back
to enemies that you used to struggle
with a lot and then disposing them
really easily because you have better
gear you have a better sense of
progression I remember as a kid being
like in arine of time for example being
super afraid of certain enemies that are
in the in the beginning of the game
because it was my first Zelda so I had
no idea how to beat them like the D
dongos for example I don't know just or
the the lizos and later you're you feel
like a God because suddenly you you you
mastered the game and those enemies
don't stand a a chance against you
anymore because you you yourself have
have progressed but also your character
has progressed and has grown stronger
and breath of wild doesn't really work
that way and tears of the Kingdom did
the same thing where it's just like
everything in the world is designed to
scale up with you and you cannot really
enter areas where you're you will be in
much more danger than anywhere else
maybe certain isopos types are a little
bit stronger that's it and it's all the
same enemies everywhere there's very
there's very few enemies that are native
to one region you will always find the
same monster camps the same type of
rewards the same things everywhere and I
think they should bring that sense of
you know if you're going to have an open
world then at least also it should have
threats that if you do walk into the
wrong area for uh for a while that you
will be in much more danger than if you
stick to the
safe uh middle of the map or something
like that you know yeah all right not to
uh just cap this and move on but we are
almost 20 over so um I'm going to go
ahead and uh yeah again totally my bad I
should like every one of these groups I
could talk to and we could talk uh for
hours on end and that that's my
we'll probably have to do another one of
these at some point um but let's go
ahead and do
outros uh starting let's just go back
and start with you
zeldor uh well I'm not really sure what
to say oh yeah tell us who you are and
where we can see more of you and uh well
um well once again um I'm Sor I am a
content creator that makes uh content on
YouTube primarily uh where I cover the
lore of the series and do theories and
basically Bally discuss everything
related to to to the series as a whole
including in terms of uh uh game
designning as well and and the way that
the story is structured for example I
made my most recent video uh is about
the the structure of Storytelling and
how to improve these storytelling in a
series um so I try to be very V varied
in that in that regard um you can you
can follow me on socials in on I'm
mainly on Twitter um so if you just look
for solor YT for YouTube you can you can
find me there so yep for very based
takes uh what's Twitter it's I thought
it was x no I'm just kidding uh so Mr
ran where can we see more from
you well uh right now for now might be
some things coming down the line at some
point or another but you can find me on
Bandit side out Bandits Discord server
I'm more than happy to talk whatever
theories you got y he's always there Al
lurking
always I've got nothing else to do I'm a
sad boy no no no it's a happy thing Lor
can we see more of
you uh so OB I spent a lot of time on
Discord um and I'm in a lot of different
Discord
servers pretty much I think there's only
a handful that I haven't gotten to yet
but for the most part I'm in almost
every Zelda Community um so laruan
historian I also have social media I'm
on Instagram
Facebook um Twitter X whatever you want
to call it I have a Tumblr they're all
laruan historian or the laruan historian
um Yes actually that's where I started
out a lot of my theories was on Tumblr
and that's where I used the name laruan
historian first um previously it was
always um derivative of my name uh so
like on Deviant Art Mr JM Zach my
initials and part of my last name um
yeah uh lots of content lots of theories
um diagrams art translations you name it
I've got it uh yeah find me talk shop
whatever you want fantastic and finally
last but certainly not least Mr Dawn
where can we see more of you I
wonder uh here on YouTube Monster ma
Twitter at monster YT I don't tweet a
whole lot and yes I'm calling it Twitter
Elon will also never convince me to call
it X because it's a stupid name it
really
stupid but yeah can we go back to
Myspace oh yes please and Twitter
Myspace
perfect Myspace too yeah can we can we
still have like music playing on our our
profile Pages like we used to yes
absolutely that was like the thing of
Myspace that that was apparently a good
idea back in the day you would visit
someone's profile and it would blast
link 182 into your speakers all of a
sudden because that's what they had in
the background or something that you
cannot do that anymore can you imagine
your profile getting shut down for a
copyright strike that would be so
embarrassing yeah times have changed man
they sure have anyway thank you all so
much for this chat it was fantastic um
and like I said every like I'm I'm sorry
that it only had to be this long um I
feel like we barely scratched the
surface in a lot of regards but um it is
what it is uh until next time keep in
touch thank you thank
you
byebye totally stole the Markiplier
outro there all right let me get the
next group in if they don't hate my guts
by now because I am terrible and I can't
yeah you
know time things
correctly Okay so we've got super Zelda
girl and I believe I've seen super Z
yeah there she is so super Zelda girl I
know you're here and let me see TR
Trends and then we've
gotanda okay starting the video call
everybody cross your fingers I hope
they're all still here I know it's been
a while
we will
see oh my goodness they're all here one
of them fell asleep oh oh oh sorry dude
God I was just waiting so long I I
literally I deserve that I deserve that
so much but I do have good news for you
what's that you guys are the last group
which means we're not going to run into
another time limit uh we can just
breathe everybody just take a deep
breath breathe out it's going to be fun
it's going to be fine um anyway thank
you all for being here today and let's
go ahead and uh get some introductions
out of the way and I like to go from top
to the bottom so Miss Amanda who are you
what are you all about hello I am Amanda
I host Zelda weekly at Zelda universe
and I stream on Twitch and I just play a
whole lot of
Zelda those are great
credentials uh super Zelda girl what are
you all about
oh I actually cannot hear
you I muted myself he there she
is new microphone still getting used to
it oh I totally get that absolutely um
so hi I'm super Zelda girl I am a
British YouTuber uh from the yeah um I
focus mainly on the Legend of Zelda
sometimes Metroid Final Fantasy and
Resident Evil uh I'm also a cosplayer
and I focus mainly on Zelda with that as
well but I'm pretty much night
90% Zelda
St hence the name yep and Triforce
Trends what do you cover
Metroid I cover not Metroid I was
actually going to say Metroid uh I cover
Zelda believe it or not I I you know you
see the Triforce everywhere in Metroid
really but um no mostly a Zelda Channel
you would never tell from behind me um
uh and I don't
upload M oh it's all good well fantastic
glad to have each of you on um now I I
am doing some like super chat questions
as they come in uh we had one from the
last group that was not uh asked but I'm
I'm going to set it up real quick it is
tears of the Kingdom any of y'all's
favorite Zelda
game right now I'm gonna say it is it is
okay cool
fantastic very cool very cool uh in that
case do I I believe this is kind of what
the question was about do you believe
that the complete sandbox system for the
world uh influenced that for you
personally not really I think it was
just the love of all the characters is
what really made tears of the Kingdom so
much fun is you know I do love the
exploration and getting to go all over
the place and ride horses and find new
Stables it was all I loved the
exploration aspect um but really it was
just like getting to revisit characters
that I remembered from breath of the
wild and getting to see how they've
grown and and just having that
connection to everything in it yeah
absolutely I think that was one of the
most phenomenal things about the game um
and with that other way let's go ahead
and start it off then how did we feel
about tears of the Kingdom as opposed to
breath of the wild whatever what are
your thoughts about it let's kick it
over to trior trends
uh hold on I actually got a notes pad up
because I I was I've been waiting so
long I actually put notes together 14
years 14 years three hours 14 years
um I mean I I really like how the
progression from breath of the wild
evolved into tears of the Kingdom
personally the law I don't think
it's it
can't it is worse than breath of the
Wilds the lore is worse than breath of
the Wilds in my opinion okay um I don't
think there's much arguing that but I
think in a lot of other ways T of the
Kingdom did expand on breath of the wild
it just depends on whether those
expansions were good for the game or not
like the Skylands and the depths is that
truly better than breath of the W's
original surface and everything to do
with that
but I I don't know I like the direction
that they went from breath th dut as the
kingdom it's also easy to forget
sometimes that it wasn't a game that was
supposed to be made in six years it was
supposed to be a game that was made in
three or four years right but then Co
hit and they did an extra year polishing
the game too so it's like you never know
when it should have released true um but
I think it was I think it was a a solid
sequel cool so you did you enjoyed it
you're sounding like kind of a six or
seven out of 10 in my I'm more of a I'm
more of an I'm more of an eight or nine
because I I really prefer the dungeons
how you sound with eight or nine yeah
I'm please must be all cursing and I'm
just kidding oh yeah no super Zelda girl
how did you feel about tears of the
Kingdom I really enjoyed it
um looking back it's been kind of weird
because at the same time there's a lot
of stuff that's kind of forgettable I
think it's because of it being being so
similar to breath of the wild but I feel
that I think um anyone who's watched my
videos will know um when I've been
covering breath of the wild that I had a
lot of problems with breath of the wild
things like while I over overall Lov the
game like the dungeons were
disappointing to me the um lack of
monster variety was kind of sad and at
times I guess felt that the story like I
said I've said before the story doesn't
happen in the time of breath of the wild
it happens a 100 years ago we're just
kind of tying up blue sends but with
tears of the Kingdom they fixed a lot of
that so I was very very happy just to
have dungeons that felt like more
classic Zelda dungeons some of them more
than more than others a even a few new
enemies is just nice to see shut up
phone sorry um and the story while it's
still a bit of a mess um the way with
like the kind of new memories the
dragons tears are not my ideal way of
having a story uh told in a Zelda game
it
is better in my what there is some more
threat Calamity Ganon never really felt
like a threat even though we don't
really see Ganondorf too much sadly um
he does feel more like a threet because
we have already seen him and we learn
what he can do so I enjoyed tears of the
Kingdom um but there are there are
things that are a little bit kind of H
Miss with me I see I see very good
answer U Miss
Amanda okay had to make sure I wasn't
muted all right so regarding Triforce I
just I just called it Triforce Heroes
what the heck is wrong with me I saw
Triforce friend and the first thing that
came in mind was Triforce Heroes guess
call us the Triforce Heroes you know
actually so you know maybe Triforce plus
one uh but no how did you how did you
feel about tears of the Kingdom just in
in general I know I kind of threw you um
a a bit more of a specific question at
first but this is just a general like
your personal reflection on the game as
opposed to breath of the wild for
instance how did you feel about it Goa
um I mean I loved both games like I
loved breath of the Wild and tears of
the Kingdom to me was more fun and I
think that's just because it I often
compare it the difference between like
Disneyland versus Magic Kingdom is how I
kind of compare breath of the wild and
tears of the Kingdom both are excellent
one created a foundation for it tears of
the Kingdom to me improved upon
everything that was done in breath of
the wild so that's what I liked about it
um I thought it was neat having all
sorts of places to explore uh the
getting to go into the sky Honestly
though I will have to say definitely
made traveling around a lot easier just
because of being able to float and fly
everywhere I needed to go um but I
thought it had like so many great
characters it's not very often that we
get to I don't think we've ever like
actually gotten to revisit I I know
we've had sequels before but we haven't
had one like this before I guess um like
legitimately in the same world
yeah legitimately in the same world
where you're getting to follow up on
events that have already happened
getting to meet people that you already
knew like you've been hanging out all
this time so it wasn't like there was
that nice just familiarity the whole
time that's what I really enjoyed about
it so I love tears of the Kingdom um you
know 10 years from now there might be
something I like completely different or
I might decide that I like when Waker
the best in years from now who knows um
but to me I think it's fantastic and
there's so much creativity you can do
with it and I just I just thought it was
a lot of fun no no I think I think that
it's great to hear um from someone who
legitimately does consider it you know
their their favorite Zelda game be it
just for now or or maybe it'll always be
whatever I I think that's great you know
because one of the reasons why I put all
this together is because um I've been a
bit critical of the game uh especially
in times uh in recent times and I just
kind of wanted to wanted to
here are some other takes you know so I
really I've been looking for some
positive takes on the game um because
here I come with something that's not
super positive so uh I think uh trios
Trends was just was just saying this um
and your name is AD correct yeah yeah
I'm probably just going to call you ad
because you know that's all good you got
a big name uh but uh as Ed was saying
um it's it's all I do feel that one of
the things preventing me a little bit
gameplay-wise from just really delving
in and falling as in love with tears of
the Kingdom as I really want to be uh
would
be not
enough good additions right so like I I
I don't know if y all have been watching
the whole stream up until now but in
some of the first groups we were talking
about uh the world of Hyrule and how
tears of the kingdom is still the same
world of Hyrule so that off the bat is
already going to it's just logical right
if you play breath of the wild first it
will remove a lot of that sense of oh
what's around the corner uh it just will
I mean it's cuz you know it's like
here's you're the first time you pick up
a Playstation controller right it'll
feel different but it'll never feel the
same the second and third and fourth
PlayStation controllers you pick up um
even though it might have a different
skin on it or it might have a different
grip on it it's still that's the same
controller so you know it's kind of the
same with tears of the Kingdom's Hyrule
but tears of the Kingdom brought with it
the sky islands right and and the depths
and these are the two obviously these
are like the two big additions to the
game as far as actual legitimate
geographical content is concerned uh so
I guess another question that I'm going
to give to y'all is do you feel like
there was enough new added area or could
there have been some more and uh we'll
start off with super Zelda
girl I feel like obviously they take up
a lot of room The Depths is literally
the whole size of Hyrule nearly and the
sky islands are there's a lot of them um
but when it comes to the deaths the the
deps The Depths
specifically um there wasn't too much to
do in there apart from finding like the
costumes which was a bit sad I do love
that you can refight bosses which I
think is something all Zelda games
should have a way to refight bosses
because that was so exciting and also
terrifying to just be oh for sure
walking and suddenly finding Kera and in
just there what's that flapping C caught
me compl completely off
guard very scary um but the depths are
so interesting I I I did I just wanted a
bit more to see with them maybe more
areas that like different biomes uh like
like the uh because obviously it's under
Hyrule like the desert above Hyrule in
the depths maybe it could be something a
bit different I mean it kind of was
going for that graveyard feel with the
gibdos that you could find scattered
there which was very cool to find them
down there as well but I feel like there
needed to be something a bit visually
different um to go along with those
things when it
comes I think it would have been really
cool to have more visually visual
differences in the even keeping them
still with the depth kind of like dark
Grays purples but just giving a little
bit something different like just adding
more diversity to the The Depths um so
it feels almost like a dark world of
Hyrule to some extent um but when it
comes to the sky islands I love them I I
love all the different puzzles I love
the giant cubes I thought they were very
cool um I love how some of them connect
to the surface like the cubes again um
there was a lot of different unique
puzzles the bosses were very cool um I
do still wish again that there was a few
different changes sorry my mic a few
different changes and like unique things
but overall I think the uh islands in
the sky were pretty fun and really uh
really what done well uh I do just find
it interesting how they are there is
less of the sky islands than there is
the depths and in all of the marketing
they just focused on the sky islands for
the new stuff I don't think anyone went
into tears of the Kingdom Expecting The
Depths especially to be the size and
take up as much room as it did it's I
was I was very very shocked just how how
big the depths were compared to the
skies um saying they focus primarily on
that in in the promotion which was very
cool I think um when it comes to like
the depths and just the amount of area
in tears of the Kingdom it's it is easy
to be like there should have been more
added but I just think they should have
done more with what was added so that's
a great take yeah like I think the thing
is I don't think that the depth is
inherently that bad if the depths had
law that wasn't just extremely random
and you have to kind of throw your hat
out to even understand half of what's
going on down there I think the depths
would be I I think people would love
them I think in a few years time if
something comes out about the
depths people might make more Theory
videos about the depths but until a big
Discovery happens uh yeah it's just it's
just that there's so much nothing down
there currently that everything is
equally plausible and possible and if
everything's equally possible then it's
like nothing really matters just yet you
know so we do need we need there to be
something you know something a bit more
tangible uh before theories and it could
be a single sentence you know imagine if
like there were a scroll that somebody
you know just happens to find and it
says like you know something about like
as per the prophecy The Depths have re
reopened can you imagine like how much
that would generate based on that one
sentence all of a sudden everything
would start connecting to everything
else and blah blah blah but that that's
how Theory works right and I love it I
know everybody here loves it um I I do I
just wanted to say real quick that biome
idea I think is is brilliant and I think
that tears of the Kingdom had the
perfect setup to do something like that
uh especially because each of the biomes
were already treated differently in some
cases they were more harsh than they
were in breath of the wild like the you
know like R Village for instance and in
some cases they were less you know go uh
Death Mountain um but I I think that
like like for instance for for the Zoras
right what if you know on the service
right they're dealing with the sludge
and all that stuff but what if the biome
of the depths underneath uh Zora's
domain is ice you know and it's
and oh yeah could you imagine that would
be so cool the closest thing we got was
the area surrounding Elden which had
lava it and I was so excited seeing that
it was so it was so cool it was lit up
entirely you didn't really have to use
any of the the light flower things at
all so it just added that kind of extra
uniqueness to that area um made it bit
more difficult traversing but it was
just very cool and when I got to the
desert area of the depths or under it um
finding all of the the gibdos I was
excited to see them because I thought oh
that's cool and this there was like a
area named like a graveyard I'm like oh
that kind of makes sense as well I just
wish that there was maybe sand or
something like there or maybe old ruins
gudo ruin ruins or even
more yeer stuff like specifically a lot
more Yer stuff in that area I just think
it would have been a lot added more area
more stuff to them I think it would have
been very cool to see also forced us to
use um our zonai you know uh
constructions in different ways you know
rather than everybody just making their
their go-to vehicle or their go-to you
know whatever or or whatever else they
they made that y'all are chuckling about
as I'm sure everybody has their own
story with uh but you know what I mean
like what if what if we had to come up
with not just a zonai construct for
getting across Little River or for
getting up to this sky island but we
needed to come up with like getting
across I don't know the desert you know
or or in the depth quicksand everywhere
sand and you know it's just more ways to
use the Fantastic systems that they
brought uh up in tears of the Kingdom
would have been awesome and we did have
a super chat question come through but
um just to make sure we get everybody's
ideas Amanda did you have anything on
the area the new area of Tears of the
kingdom was it enough did they yeah I
definitely want to Echo the whole idea
of like there being like different
biomes I love like the idea of there
being ice under Zora's domain I think
that as you know as much as I love the
game I think there was there's so much
that could have been done that didn't
like the deaths just being so just kind
of the same all over I think it would
have been neat to have
maybe either like maybe spirits of some
of pre some like characters so like
maybe not living NPCs but like that's
where the spirits of them dwell or
something um or maybe a completely
different tribe living underneath in the
depths it's I mean I know we have the
yiga but like just some other group I
don't know if it's you know maybe a
secret group of zonai or a different
group of underground gudo or that would
have been cool a branched group of Zona
like the the underground Zona I mean
there are already so many theories about
that you know uh there there are so many
theories about different branches of
zonai out there The Barbarians on the
surface the the depth dwellers you know
the mole type people or whatever they
might have been like you know you can
find the I forget what the armor set is
called but it's the one with the lights
all over it that makes Link's face look
like a uh a something the minor is that
the minor one a minor set yeah I for I
that that might be what it's called but
you know there there are a lot of
reasons to
believe that there were a bunch of
different uh tribes of zonai that just
existed in Hyrule and uh that would have
been so cool you know to find like the
one that's still out there um but anyway
great answers we do have a super chat
question uh also from RJ RJ has had some
awesome questions this entire stream um
but let's see do you think Zelda should
have been the POV protagonist of Tears
of the kingdom do you think that playing
her story instead of links would have
been a better call so that's an
interesting an interesting little switch
up and maybe we can also branch that
into another
uh another hope that I had for breath of
the wild so back in that game I always
thought it would have been so cool to be
able to play through the memories um you
know back in like same right which would
have been it would have been very
Hands-On one of my biggest
um honestly yeah one of my biggest
disappointments with both of these games
now has always been that the story just
goes and took place 100 years ago a
thousand years ago 10,000 years ago uh
your purpose is to piece it together you
know you don't necessarily get to play
that story it's not an active story you
know what I mean the active storytelling
uh that took place in previous Zelda
games uh took place 100 years ago right
and so now you piece it together that
that was something that it's it's a
style choice and it's they they did a
great job with it um but it's just not
my favorite right so do we think that
maybe it would have been cool to see uh
Zelda's POV in those
flashbacks
yes yes yes absolutely would that have
messed up the pacing at
all she's got a different you know set
of powers or what have you yeah it's so
it's so hard to think about because it's
it' have to change so many things well
yeah and you don't want it cuz right
like you see you've got a a PlayStation
back there have you played Spider-Man
yeah yeah Okay cool so the Mary Jane
Force yes that's a it's a crazy like
controversy it's like people don't like
hate that those sections especially in
the first game you don't want to end up
in a situation yeah exactly the pace in
but in the same regard Nintendo fans are
so different to PlayStation fans to
where Paper Mario comes out and you play
as peach in between chapters and
everyone goes
that's so
cool no that's that's a great takeaway
Nintendo fans really are kind of
different though you know like you know
there's there's a and I'm a floater
right I think probably most of us here
you know play different consoles you
know if I play good games right I just I
play good games and yeah don't
discriminate if it's a good game I'm
gonna play it absolutely right um so you
know there's no discrimination of games
here
I currently I'm I'm playing uh certain
games that maybe I shouldn't uh po world
and things like that but that's just
because you can give your little Pokemon
not Pokemon guns so that's funny but um
but no like I I think that it it is
definitely interesting how Nintendo
specifically crafts their stories
differently than any of the other I feel
any of the other developers out there
they're kind of Timeless they they are
they're kind of Timeless but there was a
big kind of question that came up in the
previous group that I'd like to ask you
guys as well just since we're on the
topic do you feel like maybe Nintendo's
style is too childish these days not
mature enough to pack a bit more of a
punch maybe
really I think kind of because Paper
Mario right is the example that I bought
ago that was a game that was so dark at
the time still and Thousand Year Door as
well comparatively to like other Mario
games right um and that was Nintendo's
thing back at that time but then with
the exception of like one or two moments
in origami King which I don't have to
mention
um any amount of Nintendo games
of the last few years haven't really had
that maturity to them and I think it was
um I think it was Don that mentioned uh
the Major's mask and how mature that
game was and the uh the side quest in
heno the cheese and the
mushrooms
um I think that they are going for a
more childish angle I do think that
there needs to there doesn't need to be
it's strange because obviously Nintendo
went through the Wii period right where
the Wii took off and a lot of children
like almost completely children and
families were buying their consoles for
a long time whereas the switch is being
bought by Gamers most of the time like
you'll go online now and it's not
they're not talking about the switch
like it is a child system some people
are that's just because they're
ignorant it's just because the game has
so many good games for
people yeah it's it's a hard one but I
think that I'd like Zelda to be a bit
more mature cuz I can definitely see
where it's being more childish
sorry go sorry uh I was going to say one
thing i' I've been told I'm horrible for
this opinion uh but when it came to
breath of the wild before tears of the
kingdom was announced I always thought
that at the end of the game Zelda should
have just said her thank you for saving
me and disappeared and it be just like
she had used all of her power and all of
her strength to fight against Ganon for
all that time and you are racing to save
her in the end and at the end you save
her only to find out that she's used all
her power and she just kind of Fades
away and becomes a spirit and I thought
yeah that's horrible as well it's like
so sad but I feel but that would have
been such an impactful ending and it's a
little bit more kind of darker than
anything we've seen is is sad bad right
necessarily I would I'm sorry you go
first sorry I was just say I would AR
that if if a story is able to reach out
and make you feel something not
annoyance for the story or you know
something like that not like I hate this
character necessarily even though yeah
in some regard but if a story is able to
reach out and make you still think about
that a day after a week after a month
after a year after whatever I think
that's I think that's good and for a lot
of people that the most impactful way to
do that is to make you sad you know yeah
that very well ory oh my God I cannot I
can't get through the first 15 minutes
of ory without crying I've always wanted
to try it oh but I I good I've
always I feel when it comes to maturity
and games as well when people say oh I
want this game to be more mature people
some people automatically think oh it's
going to have blood it's going to be all
vient it doesn't need to be like that I
know we've spoken about Majora's Mask
but another one is Wind Waker yeah the
game itself looks like a cartoon it's
absolutely adorable everybody knows it
switch yeah you think you're getting
Legos Zelda and then it's like super
deep and you get to the end for one
obviously you have that kind of
strikingly somewhat graphic kill I say
it's not supposed to be graphic for
maturity but that kill for Ganon is
pretty one of the best in all of Zelda
period it's so good but then there's
even little things like link and his
grandma he you can tell that he doesn't
want to leave her like this is a child
having to deal with all this and it's so
impactful playing through it and you
just you know he has to do it but it's
so sad it's little tiny things it
doesn't need to be in your face oh so so
deep it's so deep and mature it just
little tiny things can add to that kind
of thing like that
then yeah that
makes okay I know that Ed you've been
wanting to say something so I'll let you
I'll let you go for it D I'm sitting
here on the edge of my seat a pro at
waiting at this point okay all right um
I I saw somebody in the chat mention
Xenoblade when we were talking about
Nintendo games with maturity and it made
me think I think in a way the adventure
series that's getting the mature
treatment is Xenoblade right what like
is blade it's supposed to be the
adventure the mature Adventure that
Nintendo want to put out since it's
starting to sell a bit more now is that
their story heavy one who knows but when
it comes to darker moments in Zelda
especially tears of the Kingdom right
there are so many moments in the game
where it feels like something dark
should have happened and they just pull
the punch like um King
Doran I thought for sure he was going to
die I thought for sure he was going to
die good luck yeah and because of that I
completely forgot about that entire
quest line until literally just now like
I forgot that happened and now like oh
yeah he was dying wasn't he it's just
that the punch was pulled you're right
and the impact was completely gone it's
so strange like's fine I mean uh I mean
the the whole Zora section of the game
is my least favorite uh from a game play
and uh story point of
view what wrong like a mud do do you
like M do you like M to rock no um cute
but he is very
cute but they pull the punch last second
I don't know it just doesn't hit as hard
because that could have
been the defining moment of sidon's life
and the thing is sidon right he has gone
through a lot but he's not been through
much while being a grown adult he's been
through a lot as a child but a lot of
people go through things as a child you
need your defining adult moment so that
you can become a king is how I see it
and saying he he does become king at the
end
of it's like yeah having that extra
punch would have kind of made that he's
King but kind of at what cost he's now
got to deal with that as well and yeah I
agree with that I think that would have
been a good but as not like we've had no
Dead characters in Zelda before even if
they've died before it like stay with
Zoros you've had Rella and rice their
kind of connection is very very sad and
I guess kind of mature I guess like this
tiny child is dealing with the death of
his mother and you see him at
his at her grave sorry I'm stumbling but
yeah just yeah I agree with I agree with
you with the death of I feel like the
reason they decided not to have the the
King die is when you go there sidon is
pretty much dealing with depression and
I think that would have just kind of set
it over a little too much too much maybe
yeah yeah true that I think if he wasn't
dealing with depression at the time and
was just like all right I'm working to
be king and then the king died I think
that'd be okay but the fact that like
Yona had
to into it and link had to show up and
be like hey your besti is here and then
like it's like a went off in his head
and was like wait a minute I'm Prince
sidon I'm here with my best friend and
my fiance so I'm going to go save
everything I'm a fan
favorite yeah rather exactly he he lost
sight of all of that yeah yeah yeah yeah
I agree with that kind of to combine uh
both of those Notions with maturity you
know like the whole like losing Zelda
breath of the wild and then like loss in
general being impactful here's a good
question uh should Zelda have come back
at the end of Tears of the
Kingdom so the entire time right they
beat over our heads that the process of
dronification is irreversible it's
irreversible it's irreversible and it's
extremely impactful because of that when
we figure out that Zelda did that you
know oh my God and it makes the tears
the tears it makes the tears the tears
right like she the one bit of humanity
that she has left
can only cry yeah oh like I get
goosebumped from that you know like it's
it's heartbreaking it's so ah it's so
deep but then you know at the end she
does just kind of you know come back so
do we think that that
maybe maybe she stayed a dragon and in
the end you know it's a shot of Link
looking up at her and no and he'll never
forget what she did you know for or or
or do we think that maybe that was that
was
fine maybe if they did it like more of
like a post game thing where like you
had had to you've beaten the game game's
over now there's like some post game
play stuff you can do to bring Zelda
back it's like okay you but that's the
only way you can bring her back is if
you do like the post game or some
special so you know like the true ending
versus regular ending
yeah I think that yeah they should have
been if they wanted to do it right I
think there there should have been some
explanation as to why it happened
obviously we see it happen but why does
it happen
and
um I also
think there's a chance they could have
got gotten away with Zelda coming back
for basically no reason if um this is so
weird if link had his arm just never
come back but obviously they can't do
that and I don't thing is that like I
don't want it for
link
just
he's sacrificed his uh like a part of
him for Zelda I think that would have
had some
nice I don't know some I don't know it's
a very strange idea and I've not really
thought it through as much as most
people have
um but I don't know it'd be nice
symbolism no I I get what you're saying
like it was the essence of ru's light
and I think the concept at the end was
that um son
uh Sonia's time powers and ru's light
powers are what together brought uh
reverse the dronification essentially
and then you know that was the last that
both of them could do or would do or
whatever and then they were like that's
it we can rest and they peace out uh
which which is still a very powerful
moment and makes sense like it does make
sense you know because you know both of
them are as far as we can
tell besides Ides the lineage of halia
you know the goddess which we know from
scared sword they are the origin of like
light and time in like princess Zelda's
bloodline and so that makes sense that
you know they would be a bit more
powerful you know a bit able a bit more
able to pull off something like that
than uh just your average
joeo um but yeah so I just I don't know
I thought that that was a a neat U idea
for what I don't know might have brought
a little bit more impct to the ending
but not that the ending needed much more
impact I am one of the more critical
people about the tears of the Kingdom
story and even I think the ending is
amazing yeah I I end yeah the moment in
the sky that mirrored uh where he failed
to catch her at first and then you do
catch her I don't even at that point I
care that they surviv by falling into a
freaking Pond you know where in reality
they would have shattered every single
bone in their body upon impact because
of surface tension I don't care because
that was a cool moment and it was sweet
Dam it so it was such
a moment beautiful moment it was poetic
it was I mean it was amazing it gave me
those it gave me those Studio gibli
Vibes SP away I was like oh perfect oh
yeah and I love I love Studio U ji M uh
and actually the newest movie I don't
know if you all caught it if you haven't
you know the boy in the heron boy in the
that really it's extremely nuanced oh
it's extremely nuanced we could talk
about that movie for probably four five
hours or talk about every movie they've
made for about that oh for sure for sure
for sure um but this this being a much
more positive group on tears of the
Kingdom which is great um let's talk
about the best parts of the game so we
all are Zelda fans right obviously um
we've been playing Zelda games for for
years uh what is the best thing that
tears of the Kingdom brought to the
Zelda franchise and we're going to go
back to going in order um so let's start
with
Amanda that Dragon Battle oh my gosh I
loved that Dragon Battle so much at the
very end um and I just also like that it
we finally got full voice acting or semi
full voice acting because it wasn't
every single scene um so it just brought
so much life into the story so more life
more
climactic awesomeness yeah I get that
cuz like after breath of the wild breath
of the wild I did enjoy it but the boss
battles were just kind of Eh this time
we got more unique bosses again and the
Ganon battle at the very end of breath
of the wild was just kind of like uh
whatever and I'm not really like drawn
to this but then you see ganondorf's
ridiculously long health bar and you
fight all of that and then you've got
that incredible battle at the end and
you just feel I don't know it's
it's because of all the life that's
brought into it you feel more compelled
to do
everything yeah beautiful beautiful
super Zelda
girl um I feel like my favorite part of
the game uh was the dungeons uh I
absolutely love the dungeons some more
than others uh my favorite being the
lightning one it just gave such kind of
classic uh orcarina of time Wind Waker
Vibes definitely taking a lot from the
spirit temp Le and the uh Earth Temple I
can't remember uh the one with the
mirror shield and stuff in Wind Waker uh
so that was
just it so good I really enjoyed the
buildup to all of the
dungeons um yeah there were some great
like unlocking quests that they you know
the the mirrors in the desert that was
great I feel I feel my favorite kind of
buildup was the desert one again that
whole segment I just I don't I don't
know why it just really did it for me it
was really good um but like seeing
certain things before um I do feel like
my my least favorite was the zor one the
Zoro one sadly um because I just feel
like it wasn't as interesting I love I
love yeah I love Mok but it wasn't too
interesting compared to preting have
like an underwater
moment I feel I do I do feel that if if
tears of the Kingdom had underwater had
a underwater dungeon for the zorus I
probably would have liked that a lot
more because having it just kind of in
the sky and not really even in its own
confinement it's kind of just floating
there they kind of it didn't feel Zora
it didn't feel like a water temple or
something like that it felt just kind of
like water Islands but yeah I love the
dungeons the bosses especially
are beautiful I love seeing G uh come
back as well so that was really fun was
fantastic the such a great surprise the
the Zora had that mini dungeon didn't
they if I'm remember correctly I
actually thought that was the dungeon
when I first went in there I was like I
wasn't paying attention I think kind of
a better dungeon than the dungeon I
don't know I mean cuz it was really fun
and it was really like unique it had
this big old mechanic you had to master
also I just wanted to say uh we have a
super chat question coming in I haven't
read it yet but wanted to say Ed I'm
living for your pajamas right now oh oh
great thank you I'm sorry I saw it I I
was listening but then he got up to open
his door and he had these Zelda pajamas
and I was like I didn't see them that
show us pajamas show us your pants oh I
love it I have those
same oh dude get
comfy all right Ed what is what was your
favorite part about uh tears of the
Kingdom slash what is what what do you
think is the best thing it brought to
the
franchise I think it's the first game
well it's the first game since breath of
the W so it can be only be the first
game to do this but uh I think it's the
first game to have
meshed the idea of breath of the Wild
and the older Zelda games slightly
closer and I think that was the best
thing about it for me I think it felt
far more like a traditional Zelda
without being anything like a
traditional Zelda and that for me was
just about enough for it to be like my
second May third favorite Zelda maybe
first I I don't know yeah no that's
great I I think that tears of the
Kingdom did make um several strides
towards the traditional format right
that a lot of people
were uh you know CL clamoring for after
breath of the wild because breath of the
wild you know when it released it was
the I mean the goat like what what was
traditional about that right we didn't
even have heart containers um and we
still don't have heart I mean we had
heart containers but you know what I
mean we didn't have like pieces of heart
in the world and stuff we didn't pick up
Hearts to heal like from the bottom I
really miss that it was heart pieces oh
my God I missed that too it's something
that you don't really think about until
someone brings up you're like oh yeah I
miss kind of getting little pieces until
getting new Hearts just well that brings
me actually that brings up this the
other question um do you think that you
miss that because it's purely nostalgic
or do you think there is something to be
said for it just being a different mode
of gameplay I think it's a different I
think it's because it's a different mode
of gameplay I think um I think you were
talking about items as well in one of
the with the one of the other groups but
the idea of getting the items in past uh
games getting them in dungeons kind of
leads to that extra bit of progression I
feel that heart containers do the same
thing with the uh the orbs in breath of
the wild or the whatever they were the
different collectible thingies from the
shrines and stuff you get um it doesn't
kind of have that same feeling because
I'm not sure how to explain it because
obviously you do get stamina or factor
of the heart container you could just
find in like a chest or complete a side
test or something you didn't the first
time you play it you don't know what
you're about to get and it's like oh y I
got piece of heart or Y I found a heart
container and it was exciting to find
that instead of like all right let me do
this number of shrines so I can get and
they're in the Overworld they're in the
world you don't have to go to a specific
place I always remember the first uh one
of the first heart pieces you get in
Twilight Princess is like when you're
going um into the kind of uh the deeper
wood bit part first kind of when you're
trying to find the monkey I believe yeah
and you go into that cave
yeah there's like chest yeah you get you
get that one chest and you're like oh
wait there's some torches you light them
and big chest and you're like oh wow
heart piece it's just like doing those
little puzzles finding those little
extra pieces it kind of just it's a
surprise it's nice and it makes you feel
like you're kind of progressing even
when you're not really progressing
you're just getting something it's just
adds it adds to it it's nice and I think
that also goes with the items as well
items and dungeons I think they kind of
add to that progression you're you're
growing stronger you're not just getting
more Hearts you are growing slowly I
think that works quite well yeah and I
think that it could work given their um
like if pieces of heart for instance
were to come back uh I don't think it
needs to necessarily be an either or
conversation with like okay well then
let's do away with the shrines and the
shrine like you know you could easily
have some shrines yield a piece of heart
directly
and then other shrines yield a piece of
stamina and others yield piece of armor
and others yield you know whatever like
you you could very easily Implement that
and I don't think anybody would have a
problem with that and then of course
pieces of heart in and of themselves
could not only come from shrines there
could also be Overworld ones right like
it's always been that way side quest
it's always been that way you know
pieces of heart can come I'm going
through the Minish Cap for the first
time um and like there there's of course
the are the Capcom games and they always
handled things a bit differently um but
like there's a right off the bat there's
like a vendor and she's like oh Princess
Zelda you won uh here choose one of
these uh rewards and there's just a fing
piece of heart sitting right there and
it's like you know what I mean it's like
they've always been this like kind of
tongue and cheek uh is it Canon is it
not doesn't really matter it's a reward
for this it could be a reward for that
it could you know whatever but pieces of
heart have have always been a part of
the Zelda formula and uh I think that
honestly it's impactful enough to where
if that alone was brought back in the
next Zelda game
like I do think that a lot of people
would be like oh it feels so much like
Zelda you know just because we can go
fine pieces of heart now like it was
that impactful to the for if you would
you bringing up like the the Minish Cap
bit that you just said it also like like
you said they can be in stores which I
always remember finding like in Phantom
Hourglass which was my first Zelda game
finding a uh a heart container or a
heart piece in a store and realizing it
was like 10,000 rupees and you're like
okay I have a new goal I need to save up
10,000 rupees and in something like
tears of the Kingdom breath of the wild
that could be pretty difficult so that
would be another thing like another kind
of goal to work towards which yeah it'd
be very cool to do yeah from a game
design perspective pieces of heart are
like everything you know you can you can
use that for everything we have a super
chat question by the way um and after
the Super Chat question we're going to
go to the future of Zelda and then we'll
probably wrap it up from there just so
you guys know uh what's going on but the
Super Chat question is and this is for
everybody I believe besides Ocarina from
granddaddy otaku is there a Zelda remake
you would all like to see and if so
should they redo it in the style in the
style of breath or tears' open
world I want to see Twilight Princess in
breath of the WBS engine sorry I just I
I just get that one out it just
automatic just boom boom that out yeah
what what about what would youall like
to see
[Music]
remade I I wouldn't want to see it done
in the breath of the wild St style but I
I really want remakes of Phantom
Hourglass and spirit track
but in the style of Wind Waker so kind
of that camera behind you third person
like no more tapping on the screen to
make as long as you don't have to
literally blow into it then I'm sold
yeah what
me I I love Phantom Hourglass and I love
Spirit Tracks and they are the kind of
games that do get kind of the bottom of
the barrel sometimes because people
don't like the gimmicks don't like the
tapping on the screen and I totally
understand that but I absolutely love
them and I see them as hidden gems
especially Phantom Hourglass uh not just
CU it's my first Zelda game because I
went through a weird Whirlwind with that
game when I was younger
but stories
there I didn't finish it till about like
five years ago and that's when I
realized this game is special this game
has it's not the most deep it's not the
most like extravagant it's definitely
not Wind Waker but it's special it's
Charming its characters are funny and
rememberable uh linebeck and Cella are
hilarious uh oous is very funny actually
as well um it's it does feel a little
bit like a Saturday morning cartoon it's
very funny and I really love it and I
feel if it was remade in that wind waker
style in kind of Wind Waker HD Maybe
I feel that people would be like I'm
turning around on this I didn't enjoy it
on the DS but this game this game is
actually very fun and very funny and I
think people would love it I really do I
I I love fan I do agree I agree it's my
baby well it's one of those Skyward
Sword isms right it's like yeah it has
such it has such amazing stuff going for
it but it's hindered because nobody
wants
to you know what I mean like I I'm
trying to deflect the stupid just I
don't play anymore you know what I
mean playing on a Wii U oh man are you
left-handed my problem oh
no I did Spirit track on the Wii U
left-handed that
was but you wouldn't have to shut the uh
the the the the DS to print it true
which to be honest I would say
remaking in Wind Waker would like a wind
waker traditional more traditional Zelda
St would kind of take away a little bit
from those puzzles because you did have
ones where you had to blow into it you
had to scratch stuff off and shut the DS
just remember I got so fed up I got I
was like dude I can't figure out this
puzzle I'm just I'll do the puzzle
tomorrow I'll do the puzzle tomorrow I
just closed my DS I open the DS in the
morning it's like boom I'm pretty sure I
did the same thing just
tapping
it just tapping it for ages but it's
like yeah it would take away from that
like sh that is kind of charming having
to shut the DS to print the pattern on
to the map yeah yeah it really is but at
the same time I'm sure they could come
up with something else maybe add like a
new item that presses the map together
or something like that but yeah I
definitely feel like if we got if I
could pick any Zelda games to get remade
Wind Waker uh not Wind Waker Phantom
Hourglass and spirit track would be
fantastic remade and I really think
people would kind of change their tune
on them a little bit which would be very
nice and you're talking about like
full-fledged like main console 3D Wind
Waker style yeah yeah that would be
that's a dream little bit less
Bloom and then it would look amazing
what dream yeah very cool so part of me
wants to say Minish cat because it's so
great and I'd like to see that in like
the switch links away Awakening style
but the art style in Minish C is just so
beautiful that like it doesn't
necessarily need it and I think it would
be cool to do Twilight Princess in like
the breath of the wild tears of the
kingdom style where it is because it has
that like open feeling like it could be
that big exploration world and there's
so much lore in Twilight Princess that
didn't get fully explained or resolved
um I mean you can read the Manga which I
really is not like officially Canon but
it's still like it gives them a better
backstory and there's so much that was
missing in Twilight Princess that I feel
like that if they did a full remake of
it it they would make it just this
incredible like cinematic kind of game
make it Lord of the
Rings I mean saying it saying it was
inspired a little bit by the movies when
they were kind of going like how do we
get the American Market because I don't
I remember in Nintendo power at the time
they were like say hey who would you
want to play link and everyone's like
Orlando
BL you're all
16 we're all still 16 for Orlando Bloom
in our hearts but uh anyway true not not
to be you know that guy but I'm going to
have to say ocarine of time I know I
know it's roll's eyes whatever um I'm
not rolling my eyes I say go for it yeah
I mean honestly so to me like acarine of
time it's my favorite for many reasons
many reasons and a lot of that is just
pure Nostalgia I absolutely agree or or
admit that um but aine of time just has
a lot of goodness going for it that I
think is timeless and it's held back um
even nowadays it's on you know like the
the switch expansion pass even nowadays
people barely pick it up that I know of
uh because they're like it's hard to
play you know the it's held back it's
clunky Cluny yeah um and like it got
remade which fixed a lot of the
clunkiness on the 3DS but and and and
that did sell pretty well right like
there were quite a few people who picked
that up but um I'm just going to say it
there is a difference between a Home
console experience and a handheld
experience they're just uh one of what
one of them the Home console and and I
mean you can look at sales numbers alone
for for the Zelda series if if you you
know want to kind of of compare and
contrast what could be more impactful
the Home console Mainline games Skyward
Sword was was criticized by like
everybody and their mom when it came out
and it's still outsold like 90% of every
handheld title out there just because it
came out the same year as the orcarina
Remake as well right right exactly so
it's not like Zelda was doing a high or
something it was like they came out the
same year yeah no exactly so but but
that's just a testament to the
difference of impact of like an actual
like throw it up on your TV you know
have your family sit around your
siblings whatever and let's all just get
through the Zelda game together like
that's that's special and the and that
has not come back for Al Karina you know
that happened back when it came out and
then you know in the Years following uh
but ever since it's now like oh look at
how aged this game is what played on the
3D s ah why would I do that um cuz you
know maybe at this point they won't even
buy a 3DS to play it so I think that it
would be fantastic if acarine of time
had a groundup remake uh as acarine of
time you know like not necessarily
redone in breath of the wild style or
anything like that like I mean sure they
can enact artistic differences like cell
shading I don't really care uh but you
know keep it as it is but less clunky
HD you know take away the the
accessibility restrictions that a lot of
people claim are preventing them from
playing the game and let a whole new
generation of people fall in love with
that game because I H Unreal Engine hire
that man yeah I know right like just
Port Port whatever that is onto the
switch you know like unreal yeah do we
have any Unreal Engine games on the
switch maybe like an indie something
yeah
anything there I can't think of anything
off the top of my head that runs in
unreal but anyway okay um this
conversation has been fantastic let me
go ahead and ask our kind of kind of
wrap-up question which is going to be
craft for me if you will the perfect
next Zelda game and we'll go with Ed
since you've been just sitting there
staring at the
wall I'm not staring at the I've got two
anyway um
uh I always said even before Tas of the
Kingdom came out that breath of the wild
mixed with Twilight princess's Dungeons
and its story and stuff would be my
favorite my perfect Zelda game so can I
can I specify you on that or ask for
clarity yeah yeah go ahead what do you
mean like why Twilight princesses
dungeons
specifically dude there is some I don't
know there's something about Twilight
Princess dungeons I thing is ocar r and
Twilight Princess they're neck and neck
my favorite dungeons but Twilight
princess edges them out because I think
of item variety more than anything else
mhm I just love how items are used in
toilight Princess compared to any other
Zelda game pretty much plus the theming
is um I do like a mature theme and I
know dark shouldn't mean mature or
whatever just dark colors and stuff but
dude the Twilight and everything I love
the
Twilight I just think the dungeons in
that that game I I
I love them so much sure so basically
like a like the engine if you will of or
maybe not engine but like I think um I
mean you know what I actually had this
noted but never brought it up um the
great Skylands all right are pretty much
the Zelda game a lot of people want I
think which sounds crazy trust me but
think about like this the beginning of
the game you can kind of go off and do
whatever you want as soon as you've got
Ultra hand
there's the little subsection I didn't
realize this to my second playr on the
great Skylands you can kind of make your
way up to ascend the the ascent like
anytime if you want I like that idea and
it's the same with the great Plateau
right I think the beginning of breath of
the wild and tears of the Kingdom they
could be like if they made a Zelda game
that's an open zone
game I think that's the perfect Zelda
game that a lot of people are wanting
where it's very open for an area you can
always come back later just like old
Zelda games weirdly enough it is just
traditional Zelda except now a bit more
open I like I I love that yeah very cool
super Zelda
girl um kind of playing of what um Tri
Trend said if we're sticking with the
open world that I'm guessing is going to
be sticking around for at least a bit a
bit of a while uh having the world in
zones
is I feel one way Nintendo can go to
really kind of refine the open world
I've said before that I feel Nintendo
with Zelda should go kind of of what
Final Fantasy 15 did where the world is
very big you've got a lot of stuff to do
but it opens up slowly so you have a big
Zone to start with um where you can go
around there's a few things to do you've
got the main quest but you cannot
progress until you can like you do that
main quest you can go and do dungeons
and stuff but you can't really go too
far out and you are kind of always
pulled back because there is a like like
a level a level kind of that you have to
be obviously not with Zelda you'd have
to be like a
certain um certain amount of health and
it kind of comes back to what you were
saying a while ago with uh I think
another group with enemies that scaling
with you if the enemies are too hard
you're not going to be able to go out
you will have to then be forced in a way
to do the main quest and I feel that
would be very good for Zelda because it
would also then streamline our stories
because I think we've all had a little
bit of a problem with how the stories
have been told in breath of the wild and
tears of the Kingdom where yes there is
a way to go but it's kind of vague I
didn't do the dragons tears in the right
order because I did not pay attention I
was just going I was just doing them
when I got to them so having that kind
of large open sector that you can then
do and then move on I think would work
very well and that kind of is again like
what they did with the great plateau uh
imagine if you went great plateau and
then the region that has kakara Village
and you could then kind of go around
that area get some shrines and stuff but
you couldn't actually progress until you
went to kakaro Village
um I just think that's the best way that
we need to go with Zelda in like the
open world Zelda and definitely include
very good dungeons because yeah just
having the dungeons as well definitely
added a lot to my love for tears of the
kingdom sure but yeah
story dungeons those are things I love
and I want and I do want to see more
diverse um villains new villains I love
Gondor I adore Gondor this is no
secret um but I love the unique villains
that this Series has vati girim Yuga
they are all fantastic and we need more
of them even side villains
like it would do so well just for um for
you know obviously lore at the minute
it's like
earlier you guys were talking about
gondol right the last group you're like
everyone's arguing about this just make
someone new I don't care I don't care
about gondorf I mean I do care about
Ganondorf but yeah you know bring him
it's funny because technically
before never com again putting that the
sorry what were we technically that's
fine it wasn't in a game obviously from
like Twilight Princess to tars of the
Kingdom but I don't know
it I just I I feel like someone else
needs to be in there that isn't demise
where it's like it's technically Ganon
off but now it's just some to break it
up we everyone loves everyone loves
Gondor yes this is the thing everyone
loves Ganon everyone loves Ganondorf
he's like he is the Bowser of the series
you can't yeah you can't get rid of him
you can kill him off there's always
going to be some reason and some way to
bring him back literally the William
Aton he can still be there just bring
somebody bring another bad guy with them
and that's why I love um Zant because he
yes I I know Ganondorf is the main
villain but Zan's so interesting because
he friends you he's a pres the game GE
him vti even varti is
a I love him so much I want him in a
non-pixel game I just want to see what
he would look like he looks so cool he's
got such a cool design and then he can
go away I just want to see him for two
seconds I just want to see him go but
yeah just new characters I remember when
uh A Link Between Worlds came out or or
was being teased and we were getting
trailers and everyone was like who's
this with Yuga it was such a great
surprise to have a new character who yes
is probably a alternate
Ganondorf like looking at his hair and
his relation to Hilda and ravio but it
was so cool to have that new character
and we need more of that AA in a um
CRA and he
new he's new he's interesting he's not
just another Ganon copy and that's what
makes Zelda villains cool you have Ganon
who is I love but we we all accept he's
kind of the the big buff evil dude the
big strong guy with an army behind him a
lot of the Zelda villains are not that
you girim is very very poetic he's very
quick uh vti's very cunning
Zant's
Bonkers AA is also very cunning and
quite scary I think Bellum is
amazing I wish there was more even madis
and Chancellor Cole like they are very
similar to Zant and uh to Zant and G
Ganondorf or even girim and demise but
just going out of Hyrule as well you get
different villains like an and onx like
I love an and The Legend of Zoda doesn't
there's so much they can do with
villains yeah the name of the Legend of
Zelda it doesn't pretend that anything
that that's the thing right every Zelda
game is different we don't always have
to come I mean we don't always have to
come back to hyru because we don't
always come back to hyru but it' be nice
if next game go away from hru for a
little bit we hyru do it well go to
termin Leia on the flip side of the new
villain idea um just kind of bringing it
back to the whole tears of the Kingdom
negativity that I'm so well known for
these days great um no uh but but like
if tears of the Kingdom had a new
villain that was written the exact same
way as they had written Ganondorf I'm
pretty sure nobody would have a problem
with it because on the flip side right a
name like Ganondorf comes with a lot of
expectations off the bat um and so
because Ganondorf came with all these
expectations and people wanted more
about his motiv I'm right there with
those people about his backstory I
wanted I wanted right there was so many
crazy theories before he came out there
still are there still are but but I was
there making fues about him being good
exactly but my my point is like if it
was just somebody else like there
there's not a reason to be upset you
know like there's so that's that's kind
of me pointing uh pointing the finger at
myself there um because like I am a
person who knows that I I like I I have
expectations I understand that um but
there are a lot of advantages with just
introducing new characters new slate you
know it could be something different
that's not as good as Ganondorf or
better whatever or maybe he was written
better but it's just different the point
is if it's different if it's a different
character it's not attached to anything
and that's a huge
Advantage I think that's why part of why
it's exciting seeing the different
villains in the Zelda series because
they're new they haven't got that
baggage they don't need to be connected
and you don't really need to explain
where they come from because it's just a
new evil and high rule after the
Triforce after some divine power you
don't really need to explain it more
than that if you don't want to which I
think we need more
of absolutely Amanda bring us home with
this one uh what was even the question
was it crafting CRA theultimate game yes
apologies no no you're good great
conversation all right my Ultimate Game
would have the story level of Skyward
Sword just because it had such great
characterization I thought it had a
really strong story so I want story of
that
level I want dungeons that are super
themed like in Twilight Princess and I
want or Ocarina of Time either one I'm
not all that picky and then I want the
music to be like as catchy asarina of
time because I miss that like I loved
that o open world Ambient sound it was
great it was beautiful but I want the
catchy music back it was great and then
I love the exploration of breath of the
wild and tears of the Kingdom but I
would like it to be a little more lenier
I loved your idea of the the different
zones I think that would be fantastic
the final just Final Fantasy level 15 or
Final Fantasy 15 level exploration I
think would be spot on because think you
still have the fast travel so you don't
have to do that open as well all over
the place travel's still there mhm and I
you know on that note I think that fast
travel could be taken down a couple
notches from what it is currently we
have fast travels every 2 Ines in the in
the current world of hyru you know and I
think that you can do it at any time you
can do it at any point yeah what what if
you know like who raise your hand if you
legitimately not just for novelty sake
raise your hand if you legitimately
explore hyru on Horseback after like the
first 10 hours of
gameplay you know what I mean really you
see what I mean the only time I'm on a
horseback is just to sit let the horse
go and just taking the views which is
novelty right which is like oh I'm
sitting here it's so nice what the
experience of it all but I mean like if
if you once you get some travel points
unlocked you're going to just fast
travel who in their right mind would be
like no I'm going to ride my horse
across the world I once tried to do a uh
breath of the wild playthrough with
using no travel points because I wanted
to just see I wanted to see kind of my
uh Hero's Pathway to see how it looked
when you weren't traveling part I gave
up on that so fast I was going to say
this is the
game it it did go a
while I while but but it
was nah it's just it's too long and
you've got so many travel points you can
literally just BIM Bam Boom easy well
and like I you know doing these um
Theory videos and whatever as we're
we're known for doing uh like you need
footage right you need you need to
Traverse the world of Hyrule and and
grab foot foot and whatever and that's
never been more difficult than with
freaking breath of the wild and tears of
the Kingdom uh because like especially
in breath of the wild when you would go
past a cut scene and you needed that cut
scene again before like everybody has
the footage on YouTube and they have
their freaking watermarks in it
and I know right it's a pet peeve of
mine too but like so trying to get it
yourself especially if you want to like
emulate the games right and and get some
better resolution out of those beautiful
crispy in-game cutcenes like in tears of
the Kingdom um you need to do all of
that all over again you know and it
takes a long time because it's such a
big world uh it actually led me to
discovering like a light bulb going off
that I could just download somebody
else's 100% save
file I don't know why I didn't think of
that before uh but anyway that's that's
neither here nor there but it led me to
a mental breakdown so dude no it's it's
it's true like I back in the day I'm
talking like two years ago or so when I
was just cranking out like Theory video
after Theory video I mean literally most
of my week was taken up just walking
around the freaking world my rule and
just like oh I've got to get oh man this
is my new playr oh you I haven't crossed
hebra oh okay and then like you get
there because you already know to get
there but then you're like I don't have
enough freaking spices to make link warm
anyway but that's neither here nor there
guys I have enjoyed this conversation
and thank you so much for waiting first
and foremost because man that was I'm
sorry this that was on me I I don't know
what I was thinking giving every group
like only 30 minutes so anyway won't
make that mistake again uh but I could
see all of the groups everybody in each
group and especially you guys coming
back on the channel at some point for
much more in-depth conversations in the
future I hope that you would be down for
that um but for now I I think we are
going to wrap this up so let's get some
outros going super Zelda girl where can
we find more of you um you can find me
on YouTube super Zelda girl uh I'm also
on Twitch I have a Twitter
literally just just search my name on
most things and you'll find me um also
and Jester it's pretty it's pretty easy
to to find me if you like okay what was
that person super zeld girl blah blah
blah yeah I'm on pretty much any
uh the same name I post mainly on
Twitter though um need to get back into
posting on YouTube hopefully that will
happen soon uh but yeah if you're
interested in following me and want to
see YouTube Zelda content where I focus
on a lot of different things and yeah
that' be really fun and thank you for
having me by the way oh of course really
fun it's been fantastic I can't believe
it's been this long and I haven't had
you guys on the channel yet I'm a
wonderful wonderful person clearly uh
Amanda where can with we see more of you
well you can find me on socials at
Amanda vanile and you can find me on
YouTube on the Zelda Universe TV channel
where I host Zelda weekly you'll also
find me at conventions such as PC and
MomoCon talking about Zelda and on
panels there I can't remember if I said
panels or not but e doing panels at
conventions you'll find me there
basically if there's a Zelda discussion
somewhere I'm probably going to show up
you can also find me hosting the shine
sparkers podcast where I talk about
Metroid and then I also have a twitch
Channel I haven't gotten to stream in a
while just because I've had a whole lot
going on um but it is Panda Princessa
and that's where I stream and I am so
happy I got to be on the show oh yeah
happy to have you have you are you going
to PX East this year is Zelda I think
I'm planning on it assuming that because
I submitted two panels so assuming at
least one of them gets selected then
I'll be there fantastic I may be there I
may not I haven't decided yet last year
obviously it was all like oh tears of
the Kingdom tears of the Kingdom so like
all were like busting down doors and
literally crossing the ocean uh to get
here um and then it's hilarious the only
thing tears of the kingdom was a statue
it was a cool
statue so many pictures at that statue
they had the G won there as well I would
have been straight over there oh my God
I would have been on a plane yeah she
would have been swimming
oh I want to that if they have that at
paxis this year oh my gosh I will like
it would beone if I was there just there
there's Amanda just just at the feet
just like hi Ed where can we see
everything that you do or think
about I'll think about
um
Twitter uh I I'm posting more on Twitter
than anywhere else at the minute um
YouTube I have a load of ideas happening
but they're not happening yet maybe in a
couple of weeks I'll start weekly
uploads back up and then uh I mean if
you're also from the UK then me and hro
gamer are going to be in Birmingham at
the end of March so that's cool for
insomnia insomnia gaming Festival that's
I wish I could
go I said hi would you yeah of course of
course he did say he really wanted to
come but he he couldn't oh no no no yeah
I like had um I think him and then uh
William Nintendo black crisis was also
busy and then zeltic is out of town but
each of them expressed interest in doing
something like this in the future so you
know maybe it'll happen again uh it was
a pretty big Endeavor um but in the
future I think I will definitely give
more time slots to everybody anyway
that's about all she wrote thank you
guys uh for being on and I hope that
each of you know that if you ever need
me for anything
holler I'm at the other side of I'm at
the other end of Discord so just let me
know yeah yeah all right y'all thank you
for having us of course thank you so
much bye bye
bye all right guys and that